Dah,
Dah.
We are live.
That'd be the black bottle we're
discussing how annoying it is.
A,
I listened to the podcast and episode
that I did with Whitney Cummings.
I was listening to it because it had the
long drive back from Irvine and I
realized how annoying it is.
I'm always clearing my throat.
I was telling Jamie he makes the best
butter coffee,
but it's a stout batch and it gives you
a lot.
A lot of butter.
So yeah,
it's good though.
Taste goddamn good.
It's like a hug
hug.
Tate says about coffee tape from Quebec
or I'm coughing.
He says it's like a warm hug.
That's what it is.
I was with Keith Jardine.
Uh,
I kind of ran into him at the airport
and we were where we were somewhere.
I can't remember if he said,
you got to follow me.
I said,
well,
I think that's just follow me.
There's a very special coffee place
here.
And literally I'm like,
okay,
I don't know where I'm going.
And we walked a mile,
like airports brings me to this place.
This is the one place they have very
good coffee.
And it talks kind of like really Kinda
and uh,
they were closing and he said,
do you mind staying open just a little
bit longer?
And the guy was like,
look at his ears.
And he's like,
I,
I suppose.
He goes,
thank you.
We'll have a couple of these coffees.
Police guy pushes the coffees.
And then it was just so funny to watch
this brute of a man sip the coffee with
such detail and,
and break down this taste.
He's like,
lot of citrus in this.
It sounds like you're about to get
raped.
Well then I felt know,
but then I just suck this because I
don't really want to come with me.
Can you stay open?
We don't really want to just stay open.
This weird.
I'm going to talk to you about
something.
Nobody gives a fuck about flavor of
coffee now.
Now I want you to smell my breath after
I drank it and get a little closer to my
mouth.
Now let's go ahead and drink deeply of
my lips.
No,
for real though.
Keith loves coffee.
Oh,
he's the smartest.
Do very smart.
And He loves to go to coffee shops.
I remember when we were training
together,
we get done draining and he would take
off to a bookstore or a coffee shop,
put on his glasses are just read and sip
coffee.
It was like,
Damn.
I love it.
Yeah.
He's a smart dude.
Very misunderstood guy.
Keith Jardine.
Nicest guy of all time.
Yeah.
If you got a problem with keep charging,
you might be a piece of shit.
That's right.
You got a problem with all of this.
How is it even possible?
Nice.
Yeah.
He's just a very unusual,
interesting,
humble guy who fucking loves coffee.
Has this tate tate loves this shit.
Take drinks too much.
Taito.
Sit here and he'll.
We'll do a podcast together.
The motherfucker will down for Nitros.
Each nitrile is 270 milligrams of
caffeine.
Dude,
we.
We're in this.
We're in this case.
Where were we at in Texas?
In Dallas.
We are one of his clubs.
We had our after parties.
Honky tonk place.
Yeah,
something like that.
And it was bro.
I have four kegs at night.
I was like,
it's one in the morning.
I was supposed to do with it.
You go all night,
man.
You don't understand.
He's sober,
sober and he'll use a lot of butter in
that beard.
He leaves a lot of butter in that beard.
Beard was not above grabbing me about
the waste and pulling me right into his
lap.
I'm sitting in your lap right now and I,
I'm afraid to move out of the way.
She smells like a bookstore is like a
unique smell.
Like a hippie bookstore.
Yeah,
like,
like wax and tattered cover.
You call it the.
Oh,
I call it possibility.
He smells like woodstock,
but see a lot of those dudes that are
sober and you know,
I love Keith Keith tape to death.
I love both of them,
but I love to death like tate's my
brother.
I love that guy.
Does a lot of the alcoholics anonymous
guys.
Any any sobriety guys?
They drink a lot of pot of coffee.
That's like,
that's where they're getting their to
just get a little charge,
a manageable charge that doesn't fuck up
your life,
but it gives you a little.
They like it.
Some of them like cigarettes.
Unfortunately.
Coffee and cigarettes together for
alcoholics like my boys.
I don't know if you're doing.
I mean I guess you're not ruining your
life in terms of decision making with
the cigarettes.
Like it would be with the booze in your
body up though.
Still a nicotine addiction more.
It's replacing one addiction for
another.
It depends on how much you're boozing
though,
right?
I bet you could kill yourself.
Well,
you could definitely kill yourself in
one night with booze and you can't do
that with cigarettes.
No,
so I guess it's more toxic to drunk.
A lot of those addicts become like
marathon runners because the endorphins
that you get from running long,
it's the same thing.
So he get all skinny.
I was that.
I was with Joe Schilling yesterday and
it's just so cool to watch that guy just
light up to be just a world champion
kickboxer and then just smoke a
cigarette once in a while.
It's just like,
I'm so fucking tobacco.
Doesn't fucking fuck with me man.
I'll kick cancer into us.
I was like,
how long you been smoking goes since I
was 12.
Yeah.
It's unfortunate because I think it
slows them down a little bit.
Joe's awesome even with it,
but I definitely think it's a
performance detriment.
It just is.
If a sport relies on cardio is a huge
factor,
why would you personally limit one of
the biggest factors you could mean you
can mitigate it somewhat with hard
training and a healthy lifestyle and
moderation.
Only smoke a few days.
You can admit it may mitigate it,
but think about a sport where people are
trying so hard for little tiny fucking
bumps have improved at that level.
Yeah,
about one percent world champion.
Like sometimes they hold on to zero
difference between.
I mean the amount of decrease in
performance you would get from smoking
cigarettes versus the amount of increase
in performance you could get from taking
some things.
Like,
what's this shit they keep getting
popped with the Russian boxer just got
blood wod Maloney.
I mean,
what is it called?
Jamie?
Jamie.
See if you could find that please.
It's um,
I think it's called [inaudible].
Like a version of EPO.
Like it raises your redlands Novinski
explained it to me,
but a lot of Russian guys are getting
caught with it all.
Well,
but here's the thing is,
is
what's important.
It was legal until December,
but it's going back to Joe Schilling.
This is my only and I don't advocate
smoking ever.
Right?
My family members die from it,
cancer,
all that stuff.
But with Joe Schilling,
a guy like that,
if he smokes every now and then,
I don't know how often he smoked him.
If he's smoking cigarettes and it,
it allows him to be more free and
creative inside the ring.
It's almost helping them because parents
were lime to be more creative.
Maybe.
Maybe it calms his nerves.
He's been doing it for so long.
It's such a good choice for them.
So it's almost the same thing with Jon
Jones.
Man,
you can smoke a little weed and still be
world champion,
the baddest man on the planet.
We don't have to take all this winter.
You gotta wear dockers and act like
God's child.
You know what I'm saying?
I've seen people who have to be very,
very specific and correct and intense in
something a lot of times the way they
manage that stress,
the stress of competition,
the stress of living up to expectations
is they have one vice.
They typically will give themselves a
recess.
Most smoking girls,
whatever it might be.
Human beings tend to do that more than
they don't.
Most athletes don't and I would say that
was my biggest problem was I had to.
Everything had to go.
It had to be mapped out to be written
out,
plan for plan minute by minute and if
anything went wrong I freaked out and I
always wish I was more of that maverick
Joe Schilling maybe have a cigarette,
maybe go crash a Bentley with hookers
and cocaine,
but don't you think that that's maybe
like the cigarettes aren't necessary.
It's the attitude behind the choice to
make cigarettes part of your life.
Correct.
That's what's necessary.
Like that was made though when he was
much younger.
Yeah,
but he doesn't have to continue that
pattern.
It's a very destructive lot.
Like I noticed now we've talked about
it.
Yeah,
and I know he's.
He's tried to stop me.
He's tried to stop when there is my
feeling.
If you try to stop something,
it means you want to stop something,
so if you try to stop and then you don't
stop,
that means it beat your ass.
Like that is an important part of your
life where you can,
when you can,
when you're in a competition with
yourself and you can win and you don't.
This is my feeling about this and I'm
not trying to be hard on people,
but I think this is an important
distinction.
When you fail yourself,
when you decide to yourself that you're
going to take care of something and
you're going to kick an addiction,
you're going to do something and you
don't do it.
You don't like yourself as much.
I guess one of the most important things
about accomplishments and about
overcoming bad things in your life.
If you have something you're doing like
smoking cigarettes and you don't kick
it,
you won't respect yourself the same.
The only thing,
the only thing I would say though is
that sometimes liking yourself isn't so
important for accomplishing great
things.
There are a lot of people that would is
for happiness.
Yes,
yes.
But you know,
sometimes happiness can be the great
stopper.
You know,
it's like Harriet door.
When she wanted the book award,
they said,
well,
are you happy being a housewife for 35
years?
And she said,
why would anybody was happy write a
book.
I'm not saying that you have to be
suffering,
but a lot of times
I don't know that being satisfied,
having peace of mind and and even being
happy,
which of course we all are striving for
sometimes that can be a hindrance to
what got you where you are in the first
place.
And I'm speaking primarily a lot of
them,
a lot of great books,
screenplays,
films made by smoke and and so,
so in that sense,
so,
but,
but when it comes to addiction,
one of the things that they've found
that way easier to deal with.
So a lot of people say,
well,
stop smoking because it'll kill you or
stop smoking because it makes no sense
or stopped throwing because you're not
disciplined.
That tends to not.
That might work for a short period of
time,
but people always go back to their set
point and what does work better.
I don't think you should say always
because a lot of people quit.
They do,
but what?
What?
What helps with quitting from what I
have read and what I've talked to and
even in my own experience is that you
have to start associating the act of
smoking or whatever your vice might be
with something negative and associating
and even feeling the difference.
It's.
I always say about people that want to
get in shape.
If you could feel.
If people are out of shape and eat a lot
and eat food,
if they could feel how much better they
they feel.
I'm just talking about the pleasure
principle.
They could feel what it's like to be in
shape.
I think they'd have a heart easier time
going over that road to get there.
There'll be like,
you won't realize how good you feel
smoke until,
I mean the withdrawals and it's gonna
take forever to get through that point.
So that's a hard point to argue and I
don't know,
I've obviously,
but some people who have smoked,
like Ari said to this day,
he quit years ago,
still think what he said.
He still gets an itch.
I,
you'll see people smoking and we'll go,
God,
it looks good.
Like it is a powerful,
powerful drug guy.
Like schilling can't kick it.
I agree.
I don't think he wants to bad enough,
but also with,
with this Kito Diet,
I stopped all sugar.
I can't walk by Mrs Fields.
Don't welcome me by Mrs. Fields that
will freak the fuck out.
So it's back now because for a while you
were saying you don't even,
you don't even crave it.
It's only if I go by Mrs. Fields like I
was at the mall with my brother and I
was literally like,
Oh Dang son,
let me take my wall here.
Well,
you know,
it causes more of it if you go the
mentality of scarcity.
So if you start thinking this is the
last cookie on the planet,
you're going to go for it.
Oh,
it slows your metabolism down.
You know when you start going into
scarcity mode,
that's one of the things that they say
about people that were incorrectly
starving themselves.
Like you'll have like a little tiny
portions of carbs and you know,
and then your body's like,
what the fuck are you doing?
And your body slows down because it's
worried about losing resources because
no foods coming in.
They can actually,
yeah,
your metabolism slows down a hanging
onto this shit.
The only way like fasting is good is
when your body is in Ketosis because
then your body just starts burning fat.
The fucked up thing about addictions is
that this,
a evolutionary biologist,
his name escapes me,
was talking about how the fact that if
like an addictive mindset,
people who are extreme,
who,
who
need a lot of food for example,
or whatever,
that kind of mindset actually served our
ancestors,
cave men.
The idea of finding,
pinpointing what you want,
which is that deer and running after it
for three days until it falls over and
that,
that need,
that sort of left brain.
Yes.
Well it's the problem is when you take
away the fact that you have to chase the
deer for three,
three days,
you that,
that we still have a lot of that
reptilian sort of caveman mentality and
the most successful people in those
societies now will tend to be the same
people that have the same insane drive
to get,
you know,
do all the cocaine or eat all the food
or drink all the alcohol or,
or,
or the the,
or the addictive to,
to working out or to their sport.
And then those,
most times those,
those,
you know,
these people.
So to you,
those world,
those elite of the elite,
the one percenters,
they're not the funds to hang out with.
Some of them are not the guy like
Michael Jordan used to say that Michael
Jordan,
if you beat him playing ping pong,
he wouldn't talk to you for two weeks.
Right?
That's fucking be angry at you.
It was fun to hang out with.
Yeah,
and that's what produces that intense
level of focus that creates a guy like
Michael Jordan and they still don't like
themselves though.
There's a little bit of that in there,
but the question becomes,
do you want to be happy?
Do you want to be healthy or do you just
want to be successful?
Like do you want to be like some
miserable person?
It's laden with addictions that you may
or may not be managing,
but that is creating some success.
Like in the form of art,
like maybe music or something like that.
I think a lot of musicians,
there's.
There's an argument for that versus like
a bet nickelback eat a lot of Vegan
food.
Look man,
my told him
bring water.
I bet they get up early and do yoga so
much.
Shit.
They dropped some hips,
have some songs I enjoy here.
They have that one.
I see.
There's that one song that everybody has
song,
which was.
Listen.
No,
no,
no.
It's the theme.
The Rock Star Song.
Like I'm a rockstar.
Like there's like the fucking,
my favorite version of the Cypress Hill
version.
Yeah.
Your mind to be a rock star.
That's the shit,
right?
That's the best version of the back
superstars back's got.
They got their own version of it.
It's one of those are never good song.
Unfortunately.
I'd love to sample the sample up
broken nickelback song.
Here's.
There is.
But there's something that I think we
all recognize about what they did is
that there's just something sort of
disingenuous or something contrived or
something,
but it's still good.
Let me see.
Let me see if I think they're almost
fake.
You know,
like the.
Yeah,
and I can't be friends.
I think they're fake at all.
You know what I think Ben just to.
They're successful and I think a lot of
dumb people like them.
It's not that they're
good.
I think they are good.
I think that a lot you get associated
with some of your fans.
There's that and someone started picking
on them and using them as a punchline
and then it became that punch line.
Catches fire is like,
look at all the bad musical artists and
I say bad,
obviously tasted suggests subjective and
I'm just talking about my opinion,
which is my taste for me.
There's so much shit out there,
but people love it and it doesn't become
a punchline.
Like nickelback became a punchline for
white dude.
It's a little too good.
Michael had Fox fluxion Bolton was
talking about.
Michael was saying I became a punchline.
Michael Bolton was saying I was just
doing music and all of a sudden like the
right people started making fun of me
with the guy with the hair.
Yes.
And they said people started making fun
of me and I and it just caught fire and
I was like,
shit literally became.
I was just writing my music.
We had long hair and he had like a
turtleneck on a portion.
Your voice isn't bad voices.
There is some area.
Well,
my goodness,
my shit.
My man.
Michael,
you need a fucking mirror.
Ask Yourself,
what have you given these people?
He,
he's on the,
he's on the come up using those new
commercials towns and he was on the
lonely island video.
He's,
he's,
he's very talented,
but he's rocking normal here now.
Upper left upper left back.
Handsome guy.
Yeah,
that's someone's dad.
That's perfect.
A little too much makeup,
but in general,
short here,
he's got teenage daughters.
You got to go to his house and meet him.
He take his daughter to the prom.
That guy seems like a nice fella.
Hey,
does it fix the whole thing?
The hair thing was out of control.
It's almost like the back and the bottom
was to distract you from the top.
Who Do you think some weirdness going on
at the top was just like weirdly
cropped?
Just a hot.
Trust me.
There's a guy who tried to disguise
boldness before.
That's exactly what he's doing,
but that's what guys,
etc. But what happens to guys?
That's what happens guys with guys.
If a dude is decorating himself a little
too much,
if we all go,
hey man,
what's the guy?
The guy's got Bracelets.
Why is he wearing bangles and what's
what the tiara.
I can't.
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
You walk into this room and it's got too
many girls have american deerskin
outfits with the tassels and he's got a
bear,
a bear claw necklace out of my medicine
bag.
I get the fuck out.
Get the fuck.
He better be a shaman.
Carries throughout popery night.
He better be able to suits and a good
one.
How many bracelets can you have before
you were an asshole?
god,
that's a good question.
I have like a gang of those bracelets.
Unless you're fucking criss.
Angel.
Randy coture.
Chris.
Hey,
chris angel's?
Nope.
Hey randy.
Randy.
I love your broTher.
Is he wearing?
Is he wearing a scarf and a tank top?
You gotta.
Make up your mind.
What the fuck's going on randy?
what kind of weather are you expecting,
sir?
I don't know,
but I'm ready.
Hey,
you know what?
He gets away with it.
It's a fucking free pass for everything.
You can wear the bracelets.
You can wear a scarf.
He can do no wrong here.
What?
What happened that made him say,
I need this scarf.
Stylists.
Come on,
look,
he's got another scarf.
Stop for a second.
This is randy fucking kotex in America.
America with multiple time world
champion,
one of the toughest guys that's ever
walked the face of the planet earth.
You don't need a stylist.
hollywood got to and went.
You know what make you look better.
scarf.
He needs.
He needs us wearIng a fucking scarf.
He doesn't need a scarf.
I'm going to get that.
Know you would wear a scarf.
You son of a brandy,
whereas one.
So why can't I?
Holy shit.
Whites in so many scarves.
She likes scarfs.
The guy likes scarves.
Yeah,
he's.
I don't understand.
Maybe it's silly if someone fucks with
me.
It takes it off and kills him with it.
He just ready for a sandstorm.
Nikki chokes me.
Chokes.
But he thinks it'd be,
do.
She'd wear a black belt around his neck
everywhere he goes.
Legit,
legit point.
he came to 10th planet inbetween a
career.
Like when he,
before he came back and fought tim
silvia,
he came to 10th planet and he did,
um,
a grappling match with jacques rey.
Do you remember that?
He had a grappling match,
jacques rey rico pep rally,
who was one of the most important guys
in the early days of mma as far as
incorporating wrestling and submissions.
Rico was a huge,
like a asset to a lot of guys that were
just starting out and um,
and to this day has like,
has helped a lot of like mac danzig was
working with ricoh before he retired and
it was like his last few fights and was
like,
rico is a fucking genius.
he knows so much.
And he was like one of the early guys
that was like a rest where that was
tapping out black belts like he was.
He was like really,
really high level wrestler.
In fact,
he's in the Mark Schultz documentary.
Foxcatcher Mark Schultz wrestled him,
I'm pretty sure.
Yeah,
he went well.
A rico was a ncaa champion.
I believe he was an olympic alternate.
I'm not sure,
but I know,
I know it's super high level wrestler.
And then on top of that,
super knowledgeable about submissions
created a professional submission thing.
And so randy for jacques rey and this
professional submission thing,
and he's so strong shock or a tried to
lower leg lock them.
He had his leg,
he couldn't fucking straighten it out
rather than just doing like leg curls,
not straightening.
Captain America son got these grappler
string with hundreds of years of,
of squeezing things to 45.
Uh,
leo machida in toronto.
It's the week of the fight on their
parents for a ufc.
And uh,
I see randy in the hotel.
I've maybe met him once before.
He goes,
hey man,
you're a good striker.
I need you to help me tonight.
This is the night before the fight.
Like,
huh?
He goes,
I need you To help me.
Okay.
He had some gym book,
extreme tours in toronto.
We jump in hummers where they got them.
I have no idea drive to this location
far as hell.
I'm like,
what the hell am I going to do?
And so the night before the fight he's
doing round son.
You're not.
Most guys just do like,
you know,
he's already made weight,
most guys just kinda break their wind
and loosen up.
Oh,
not not captain America.
Oh no.
He had all his coaches there and his
striking coach,
some couldn't get into the country for
whatever reason.
So they all big broWn hair,
hold mitts for him.
I don't hold mitts.
I hit mitts.
I don't know if they know that I don't
fucking hold mitts,
but they're like,
we need your sound stand south pole and
every minute a new guy's going to rotate
in on randy for five rounds.
I was like,
the night before the fight between and
contouring,
I'm like,
fuck,
I'm,
I'm gonna do what is this case says?
So his coach would go on different guys.
we're going to be different situations
and I'm trying to hold mitts.
Mind you,
I've never,
I don't hold mitts.
I have to stay in south polk loading
machida.
Oh.
And randy isn't hitting them.
Like just feeling out.
This dude fucked me up.
I mean go hit me in the chin nose.
Bloody nose.
Pick me up,
slam me.
And I'm supposed to just let him do
whatever he wants.
This dude fucked me up every round like
god damn iT.
So he wants you to hit pads and then
shoot doubles and you know,
he's gonna shoot doubles on you and take
you down and hit you as well.
Yeah.
He was like doing this setup where he
would,
uh,
it was like a straight right left hook
and then get in on a single leg and I
was like,
god man,
you're,
when you come in and strike and I feel
like you're open for it because his
setup,
again,
I don't know,
random.
I didn't train them before that.
So I didn't feel like I was in the
position to say anything because I feel
like you're opening yourself up with
liotta man.
He's not going to be there.
LIke,
you're coming straight at him.
He's not going to be there.
I told his coach them,
I'm like,
no,
he got this,
you know,
he's been there before.
I was like,
yeah,
for sure.
Training,
couture,
pan,
watching the fight tooth.
He got knocked out like way to go shop.
You're the son of a bitch.
Jumping,
jumping front kick is what I meant.
I think it was.
Yeah,
that's exactly what it was.
I was in toronto.
That was the biggest event ever.
How about,
how about when Jack Wright did to a
vitara this weekend?
Damn.
Yeah,
he's a monster.
I don't think that was very surprising
though.
Oh,
well,
it's.
This is the vittorio you're looking at,
you know,
this tour that you're looking at right
now is with diminished hormone levels.
30 nine off,
which going to has legs look so skinny.
Ennis asked wasn't there and you can't.
You can't.
There's like there's only so much your
body can do if you're not supplementing
your hormones after a certain age and
when you see guys that fucked with
steroids most of their life and then
tried to operate off of them.
You have real problems.
Just kickstarting your endocrine system.
Stefan,
employee overeem,
testing.
what's up?
Well,
he's.
He's figured out a way to get down to
240 pounds.
He's younger a little bit.
Then first of all,
but he's figured out a way to get down
to 2:40 and maybe it doesn't have as
much power.
Who I think when he's realizing now is
technically like as a striker,
he has had a fucking very high level,
more technical than anyone use the same
mistakes.
He's made mistakes in some of his fights
and the mistakes in his approaches.
Mistakes in like how big he tried to be
or running out of gas.
Like in the travis brown fight.
When travis caught him with that front
kick to the face,
he would try to finish guys off and they
didn't finish that guys off.
He'd kind of be fucked and they'll land
on skills.
there's also with winkeljohn that that
fucking jackson team,
man,
there's a lot of great people for him to
train with.
He's really skills.
I'm just saying now that he's one of the
guys where you see drug testing kick in
and obviously he looks completely
different,
but now he has to adapt the way fight.
He has more skills in the heavyweight
division thAn anyone else.
When it comes striking.
It's not even close to grand prix.
He wanted the grant
technique is so fun to watch and he
donald,
we'll spar with them and says he just
learns.
Watching the guy,
but this is what I'm saying is he's a
guy where this strict drug tests testing
kicks in.
You can see a physical change and he's
still doing well.
He's better,
he's better in fights.
More cautiously.
Doesn't ask.
He's fighting really smart.
I'd say smarter,
not cautiously.
wastewater [inaudible] used to come in
like a meathead because he has so much
power.
Yeah,
exactly.
And that allowed him to get clipped and
I think that when you're seeing them
fight now,
like especially perfect examples,
junior dos santos like he not junior dos
santos and a lot of people like god,
maybe juniors,
maybe he's done,
you know,
maybe it's just not the same anymore.
And then junior comes back and bites
brand ben rothwell it looks better than
he's ever looked.
Yep.
So junior looked fantastic and then you
realize,
oh,
overeem's a good.
He's good.
So explain to me why ground pre k one
champion.
It's just so much better.
She's the biggest of the big evolve.
Especially at the time when he did it.
It doesn't exist anymore,
but at the time when he wanted it was
badr hari gauguin saki.
The fucking stress in the world.
Best peter hertz.
These,
these guys like that one.
It the guys that are.
I mean he wanted it on a banner and
esther,
who was.
When you go back to like the,
the history of k one,
god damn andy hook someone who was the
greatest strikers of all time.
The most entertaining,
exciting,
wild,
crazy fights between the heavyweights
and they would knock each other out all
the time.
Sam.
Sam,
she'll.
I mean,
you got some monster.
Oh my god.
Send me shit.
Good luck trying to get in on that guy.
Seven feet tall.
Could it front kick the shit out of you?
How the fuck did he not play
professional basketball,
but dude,
he was such a good kickboxer wish.
I just wish there was more money in
kickbox especially back then.
Do you remember when keratan off took
him down at,
mounted him and just punched him in his
same.
I over and over again.
He was screaming.
You bet your sweet ass.
That was one of the most disturbing.
LIke finishes have a fight.
Keratan off.
took semi shell downer at the god on
top.
I'm karatani was a monster,
scared the shit out of him.
He was very scary because some russian
military dude and he,
he was beating semi shit.
Like he was torturing a prisoner.
Like I'm not even kidding man.
He like found a like uh,
he,
he isolated him,
got up,
got on top of him,
pin him down and then kept hitting him
in his cut.
I,
he say though.
Yeah,
the same.
I just hitting the same and send me shit
was just screaming at one prisoner of
war stuff like you had some info that
fuck you.
Exactly what it needed.
It wasn't Good man.
It wasn't good.
There was something crazy about it.
It was like,
whoa.
You came into strikeforce and did work
to know that.
Well we thought arlovski was done after
he smushed orlowski member
murked all lawsky mean he's a k one.
Stryker is a beast to hold different
things.
I mean he's not the best of kate one.
You know,
he gets beat by the best guys in k one,
but he's at a super high level.
It's striking is no fucking joke for.
It was really good too because He,
he did a lot of box and had good
defense.
Beat the fuck out of over him,
beat the fuck out of my room,
knocked them outstanding.
So cracked him.
Had him running away from him,
running away from him and then he folds
against them and then when they fought
strikeforce,
they just never moved him over.
Yeah,
I guess not.
I wonder what happened.
I think he had some injuries for awhile
too.
I believe.
I believe he had some,
some issues and he gained a lot of
weight beCause of it.
remember he got like real heavy.
Yeah.
Because he lost in the heavyweight grand
prix.
That [inaudible] he was in that he lost.
What do you think is going to happen?
I won't say barnett.
Huh?
And barnett?
Beto.
Jimmy am I going crazy?
I remember that fight.
What do you think is going to happen
when steve pay fights over?
That's next one.
Hundred percent.
If you look at their scheduling to the
boat,
they both fall around the same time.
Overeem's next.
He's won four in a row.
He's the guy for the job.
they're both there.
I tHink you have to wait until travis
browne fights.
I'm cain velasquez,
I think when cain button,
but this is my thought.
Cain velasquez,
if he beats travis brown and some
spectacular way,
they're going to be calling for him to
fight for the title.
That's the toughest fight I think for me
only because travis will be in his grill
if it's for healthy travel,
if,
if cain is in shape and that cardio
thing and just in his grill boxing,
getting close and wrestling,
I hit the better east probably at least
as good a wrestler or a better wrestler
than state back.
Cain is overwHelming as
fighters I suppose as a person who's
watched fighters my whole life,
like watching the ufc,
all the thousands of fights,
I'd never seen a heavyweight that can
put the kind of pressure on somebody
that came care.
He's just different.
His cardio is just different.
It's crazy.
It's like he's got double lungs.
I'm not even joking.
Maps.
I've been overwhelmed.
Watching his fights can be an argument.
He's number one best heavyweight of all
time.
He can.
I do argue that,
and you know,
people get mad at me,
they say fado is number one,
like,
nah,
maybe.
No,
I don't think so.
Look,
I don't,
I don't.
I really think that you have to be open
minded about this number one debate and
I think until silverdome just got
knocked out for dumas in the running for
the debate 100 percent.
I mean the system is in his prime
really submits minotauro and I don't
think fader wasn't as prime though.
That's why I disagree.
He was the first guy.
He was the first guy to do it when it
was faye door and then after that it was
a guy he did gain already,
but I think he was already on the slide.
He was sitting there was still that kind
of prestigious like app after he lost
that and it's like,
oh fuck it.
Coaches.
Coaches were saying that his view,
his own mma coach after he knocked out,
brett rogers said that fate or one with
his old tricks,
but he would have liked to have him for
more time training and he thinks he's
not.
He's not approaching it correctly and he
just won by being fatal,
but he also caught,
oh,
uh,
for dme with that old trick.
He caught him,
knocked him down,
and then the mistake of federal members,
he jumped into his guard,
but remember he jumped into pounder,
but he caught him really,
really well.
Knocked him down with the exact same
time that he did to everybody before
that.
So maybe,
or maybe verdugo goes down on purpose.
The moment a punch hits him so he could
drag you into which he does.
Yeah.
He's a smart guy.
He's a very smart guy.
Fight smarter than saturday.
Definitely did not face first because he
got tagged.
If you watch the stoppage,
if you see,
if you can find the highlights,
I'll show it to you because this is
something that I wish somebody brought
up during the actual commentary.
He got tagged right before he got
knocked out.
He got tagged on the same thing with the
right hand.
He moved forward.
He was making these advances.
He got tagged with that right hand and I
think he was on queer street and I think
he went running at steep a on queer
street and got knocked the fuck out and
the way steep a did.
It was a fucking work of art.
The angle it was forest baby step to the
right.
It's better,
better.
His angle was sick and obviously his
right hand was nasty.
It's also volume did get hit early and
in training if you've seen him trained,
there's this competition within that.
Jim,
when you get hit it's like,
oh,
got to get them back more.
He gets hit and he was like,
go charging bull.
And was like,
fuck this man.
I think it's probably a little of both.
I agree because I definitely think both.
He got crack crack and I'm like,
well that is a big right hand that he
got hit with and it's in the same
manner.
The same enters charging for it.
He got hit.
That's how although got knocked out
against mcgregor.
Yeah,
you got to be fucking real careful
charging for
[inaudible] and steve bay's not got some
great guys,
but he's not a knockout artists per safe
compared to like a Mark Nelson.
He's not knockout artist.
When the guy's charging in like that and
then you're counting with right hand,
it makes it seem way worse.
Well,
here's my take on steve based power.
I think steve has big power,
but I think he fights economically and
intelligently.
He's a smooth fighter boxer.
He's a very good boxer,
a golden gloves boxer,
but he's like smooth and relaxed in the
way he spars.
It's one of the things that makes them
so dangerous because as he does things
very correctly,
you know,
and I think,
dc was on the commentary for the ufc
recently who was talking about getting
the rub.
You know,
he was talking about that experience.
When you have a tough fight with
someone,
you get the rub and he fought junior dos
santos and they went to war.
What do you mean rubbed the.
This is what I mean,
what he was saying.
He's like,
daniel says,
when you fight someone that's really
good and they're better than you,
even if you lose you,
it elevates you.
You get the rub,
but just by sharing the ring with them,
just by being in that,
by competing with them,
you realize how good you are to actually
get better and you realize how good that
person is.
Yeah.
I think he got the rub when he fought
junior dos santos in a way because he
went five rounds with a guy who was the
one of the toughest of the tough guy was
at one,
you know,
a champion and knocked out cain
velasquez was one punch and he went five
hard rounds with them and the decision
will,
could've went either way and,
and took his best shot.
Yeah,
and I also think that to go back to
[inaudible] point and your point with
the rub,
I think at the ufc level,
special wouldn't get in that top
echelon.
You know,
you're getting,
people are telling you you're good,
but like when he beat arloski,
you know,
starched them.
You don't learn much from that man.
When he go up to a decision with a world
class guy,
then you know like you're doing
something right,
your camp,
you're doing it right,
you had good gas,
you realize what works,
what does it,
so you've learned so much more and he's
going to,
like you said,
more with jds and we see them getting
better and better.
What's really interesting now is here's
the dark horse.
Nobody talks about stephan struve is
only 28 years old.
That fucking dude is gigantic.
He's seven feet tall and if he could put
it together and he put it together on
big foot silver the other night,
knocked him out.
I love the guy has a bunch of knockout
losses.
I know he does,
but he knocked out steepbank.
Struve not got steep and that was his
only loss than the ufc.
Yeah,
let's do,
do struve do not count that guy out.
Stripped at an inside leg kick and then
at least got that heart issue and stuff.
Well,
I don't know what he's got going on
physically,
but I'm saying that kid,
if he puts it all together when you're
seven feet tall,
how long does it take before you even
get coordinated?
RiGht?
I mean east like you're sending a
message and it's got to go so far before
it gets to your fucking hand.
And then,
I mean,
have you thought you guys are super tall
like jack man,
those guys?
I mean like the thing is,
is steep,
steep based struve would be such a
fricking handful of.
Could learn to use his reach,
but you guys like Roy Nelson.
When you get these upper echelon guys,
you know,
nothing gets big foot,
but off trt or whatever the case he
actually needs it offered.
It's I think anyone that top 20 kinda
fucked him up.
But with struve,
the real testament who they give them
that because that's true.
Got fucked up.
I overeem and overcome those toys.
Superintelligent fight the way father
took him down.
Beautiful.
Take down on top of him.
Just ground upon the show about
struve's.
You gotta realize that kid has I think
40 fights.
Yeah.
Here's a shitload of miles out.
Well,
his heart,
heart and the market.
What will have to design it?
No,
but it's.
I don't know what he's got.
What is the medical condition?
I forget.
We have the same manager,
so he deals with it all the time.
That Mark Hunt knockouts,
jesus christ.
Mark hunt with that leaching left hook.
Shattered his face.
Oh,
tude mark on it.
So fucking been caged.
Sad scene that.
Oh,
it's fast.
Too fast,
too steep a can get.
I,
I'm,
I'm curious to see if steve can get
within boxing distance of allister and
take away any of those kicks and how he
sets it up.
It was going to be interesting.
Alster combox man.
He can't.
Oh yeah,
for sure.
Better than.
I'm just going to tell you.
Knocked out junior with one punch.
That's good.
He's the best striker in the ufc
heavyweight division maybe of all time.
So.
So steve.
Steve bay then is going to have to close
that distance and knocks him.
Not necessarily.
Steve bay could crack him.
Look,
ben rothwell knocked him out in the
first round.
Cep has better,
can happen,
and footwork and has been stopped a lot.
Chins the question.
ThIs is the thing people forget with
allister.
The motherfucking grapple.
Oh yeah.
In wrestling.
Grapple his ass off.
So you want to go to the ground with
them?
You're gonna be in a world of trouble.
Well,
he won the abu dhabi european trials and
in pride he submitted vituro.
He's got an.
He also submitted Mark Hunt.
He has a nasty good team.
Dude.
Zoos.
I always forget about just as a striker,
but you want to get to the ground.
I don't think steve bay has a lot of
submission.
Work under is so steep and I trained for
two years together.
That kid has submission defense.
So you know,
rashad is his black belt.
If you ask god to show you like a homo
plot or a real specific,
uh,
offensive move,
it's,
I don't think at that black belt level,
but his defense and that defense is nest
super nasty.
It's jUst what?
He's really good at.
Defense.
He's a very smart athlete,
you know,
and in good it's when you have a guy
who's like,
who could probably be a professional
ballplayer,
right?
You will see bay.
He could probably be a professional
ball.
He didn't make it.
Yeah,
he didn't make,
but he's at this level of an of an
athlete now.
What I'm saying is it's rare that you
see a guy like that who comes over to
mma and fights like super technical,
super smart,
who's also really,
really tough firefighter.
Yeah.
For professional,
full time head.
His head is the biggest head I've ever,
ever seen into large set.
Nicest guy.
He's a great guy,
but he's.
He's got a rare set of attributes,
meaning that he's at pro sports athlete
level,
like as far as like his,
his ability,
his movement and his intelligence and
his approach and his training and then
on top of that he's tough as fuck stuff
is tough as fuck.
Like in this fight.
Let me tell you something,
dude.
I wAtched this fight,
very careful and one of the things that
I was noticing was like how calm he was
through everything through the walk,
when they watched,
when they're staring each other down.
One of the things you Really pay
attention to is the shortness of the.
If you watch people breathing during
nervous situations,
a lot of times even if they look calm,
you could sort of see this uneasiness in
the way they're taking in oxygen.
You're sensing tension.
You don't see.
You don't sense any of that shit looking
at,
you know,
what's impressive to if he doesn't Come
from like a mastermind camp.
No,
it's just his boys and cleveland.
Well,
he just might have a mastermind can be.
There's a lot of masterminds out there
that don't have the right pupil.
I'm saying He's not from like a
jackson's ha att.
He kicks his shit within cleveland and
does work and then goes and saves people
from burning buildings.
Who else is in that?
Um,
that camp is the guard style.
Mma.
There's also the.
Isn't there a leslie smith from there?
No,
it's not raquel pennington.
Right?
JessiCa?
I know.
It's just guy jessica,
jessica,
um,
so they have tough fighters.
it's just like if A guy's like a really
skillful trainer and you know,
you've only been doing it for a few
years,
you have to wait for the right guy to
sort of walk through your door.
Then walking through the door with eddie
bravo with eddie bravo.
Took forever for him to find someone who
could do his style and,
and prove in competition that it's very
effective.
Not just with him.
He had a unique style or his brother or
dad.
The guy with the mustache and I look at
that guy with a mustache guys.
Awesome though.
But you talked about steep ap column.
Remember he's finding right now.
That guy's not that old.
Brian.
Why are you calling that guy?
His dad aNd his older brother,
his older brother.
I guarantee it.
Just some fucking thick dude.
You know,
eddie bravo had a real good point about
this.
We were talking about it on the phone.
He was like,
fabrizio looked too relaxed.
He like,
he was coming up to the,
to the ring.
He was making that face that he may say,
yeah,
so sick of that face.
Oh,
he's being funny.
It's being silly.
I don't think theRe's anything wrong
with a fighter trying to stay loose.
I don't at all.
I think that's one of the things that
fabrizio does to have a good time.
He likes to make that sale.
He's also been doing it forever.
He's the man he's supposed for over to
him.
If he won the fight and made that face
number one,
say a fucking word.
If he went out theRe and head kicked,
steep meo chick,
you know,
no one would say a word,
but it didn't work out.
So when It doesn't work out,
that's when everybody comes shitting on
you.
It's the same.
The same with connor.
Connor.
Connor is walking out like rousy.
Same with rhonda.
When ronda lost everybody's mad at all
the shit that they loved her,
they loved her for,
don't be a do nothing,
bitch and fuck you.
I'm,
I'm making it to the top.
Kiss my ass.
Or they hate them.
They now they think she's arrogant.
Same with content.
If oh shit,
he's in venice right now,
driving around a royals royce just
wiling out.
Look,
I just,
you know,
it's just what comes.
It's part of what people love about
people bragging or they want to bring
you down though,
man.
No matter how I look how loose steep it
looks because loose.
I mean he's fighting for the title nice
and loose,
so he moves away keeping the argued.
He should have got titled earlier too,
but he's like,
he's just such a nice guy and a lot of
checking to.
Lot of good checking of kicks.
Her kids more ties,
very good luck,
very educated with his movements and
look for breezy has got some fucking
nasty kicks man.
And he's like right there.
His striking is much improved.
We saw in the travis brown fight,
man over dangerous on the statement,
the last fight,
dude,
his striking is fucking legit.
He's long as shit and he's got
confidence in it.
That nice switch kick their butt.
He's a beast.
I think in order to be that dangerous of
a fighter,
you're going to have to open yourself up
a little bit.
Then when he fight a real strategic guy
like steep a year,
didn't get a little bit of trouble.
Well,
I think what happened in this fight in
particular is that he forced it.
Yes.
Thank.
He was in this gigantic soccer arena.
It's the biggest crowd in history and
mma in Brazil.
Look at that beautiful leg kick though.
Yeah.
The inside the chat doesn't have that.
It's all nice.
Like the technique is real nice,
but I think for breesa was just so
ramped up because there's all these
people in Brazil and I think he's a
confident man.
I think he thinks he's the fucking best
in the world.
He just has to get ahold of this dude.
There's a right hand.
He nailed right.
Right.
See,
so now we can take a shot tab.
But now.
But now look,
he's forcing it.
Forcing it because he landed at.
Yeah.
So watch.
When he starts to force it,
he gets hit real hard and then he gets
hit hard and knocked out.
He tried that knee,
tries forward and when sees he got a
terrible single attempt there.
That was like such a.
You're like getting steeper on that.
He was also,
I mean he might've been just trying to
make them work.
Maybe open up possibilities can drop in
his mind,
right,
and range.
So he's not afraid to just be right in
their grills.
Not toby,
he's not writing range,
but he's real relaxed.
Like even the waste throwing that tap,
tap,
tap.
Now like he's economical and when your
economical and a five round fight,
it's super difficult chat.
I was a very nice lady by fabrizio.
These timing,
that jabin great inside.
Located in the jab also is super light.
Like he's just floating it out there.
Pop.
There's nice lock.
Step 20 jeff,
so he steps to the,
to the side there like that.
Like look at that jacket,
like that is to,
you know,
he's not just no tension there.
You know what I'm saying?
LIke it's like flowing.
They check that link again.
Nice leg kick by.
Steep.
A nice switch.
So right now for me was realizing like
okay,
this is an easy
part.
That's the one you're reading right
here.
Bang.
That's the chaos.
Now back it up again.
Watch.
Just just back it up just a little bit
to where it's chasing them.
So watching these chance he got rocky.
Ideal player is really
your problem.
You're right.
I saw that correct though,
joe.
I didn't see that until.
And he got mad and he came out.
Yes,
yes.
He got his tag.
Yeah.
He got tagged hard with that right hand.
That's right.
And then he kept charging and then he
got face planted with the second one
that,
that first right hand had him on queer
street.
I guarantee you because he's moving
forward and steep aid drops it in on
them and it's the same punch he knocked
him out with and when,
when steve bay throws a punch and this
is how,
you know he's good at me,
obviously it was fucking good,
but this is how you,
you know,
techniques at a real high level.
His arm is like loose and then he throws
it and then as it gets to his face he
tightens it down and does this stack
like as he's moving away he's like,
it's a super efficient,
like really technical punch to the
throat that way.
Moving back back in that sense,
it's very much like what anderson did to
forrest griffin.
It's also calculated because he threw it
twice and they both land in there,
but you can tell they're working on it.
He threw,
he threw the.
The left hook twice to check,
right?
Yeah.
Moving back,
moving back to the side when he does
that or if it doesn't even necessarily
have to be that he planned it out and
that was a part of the game plan.
I think steve bay does that.
I think he's a really good striker.
If you look at his Movie and I think
you're looking at a guy who's super
fucking determined,
man,
steve bay is super determined and when
you're a guy that's that focused,
you're going to get fucking really good
at everything.
So after he gets that fight,
that jab,
jab,
so flu,
it's like an upper country and it is
too.
It's so like everything he's doing is so
relaxed and efficient.
You don't see a lot of jabs in february.
Can see a lot of jabs,
like my all time favorite fighter.
Probably.
If I were to tell you who I was most
excited to see,
fight is probably vandelay.
Boom.
See that right hand.
He's russian is fucking hurt here.
Yeah,
he got mad.
He didn't just get mad.
His legs jolted.
He had like you could see his legs
stiffen up When he got hit by that first
right hand.
He got hurt and then the second one face
plant some steep.
Pays a dangerous guy.
He's not going to make mistakes.
They cleveland.
Let's get our boy a goddamn parade.
No one.
When shit.
No shit.
Hey lebron.
You want a jacket?
The other ufc fighters.
How would you tweet out about steeping
your boys from your fucking hometown?
He jumped off the fence.
He goes,
I'm the world champ.
I'm new world champs.
Yeah.
Man was like,
it was like coming into his.
His,
his,
his mind like,
is this real information?
Hey,
lebron.
Did that just fucking game of fucking.
Yeah.
I love it.
I love that man.
I love him.
I love what he stands for.
I love watching them as a fighter.
I love that he could do that.
I love it.
I love that.
He did it in Brazil.
Look at this.
you to watch this.
Watch how fish.
See it's like tank.
Oh yeah.
He just drops it in,
um,
to,
to be able to time it that good to look
at this.
Watch the timing.
Timing.
He pushes his hand away and then put the
same hand.
Did you see overeem?
Overeem's tWeet.
Crack.
Yeah.
He wants to fight him.
He said you're next.
And he did the blood sport meme.
See that?
That one showed both that.
That would.
That highlight right there was the
perfect highlight to the right because
it showed the first one.
How much impact the first one had on
him.
The first punch was a big factor there,
man.
That first punch had him weird up.
Unbelievable
man.
So cool.
I'd like to.
You could still say queer street and
you're not a homo queer streets.
fun.
It's queer.
It's just strange.
You know,
like what,
where am I at?
The heavyweight division's fun right
now,
man,
because I don't think we're gonna see a
champ.
Rain for a long time.
I want to make a shirt that says fight
for queer street.
Oh,
well,
how about,
hey,
how about queer street fight club
thing that's sending out the wrong
message?
Might be,
it's like a bat signal for dick talking
about
queer street.
You'll learn how to throw a right hand
and fuck guys.
Come guys.
Let's take a second break.
I put up a picture the other day on
twitter of the oak ridge boys.
Somebody sent me a picture because it
looks like us exactly like you.
It really does.
One of them looks like you and me had a
baby,
but one of the things that I was
shocked,
I was like,
someone said this is this looks like you
encountered,
but I go,
oh my god,
how gay with the oak ridge boys killed
me.
Wait,
wait,
when did you see this picture?
You're going to go.
Well,
that's not real.
No,
that's real.
This is the actual album cover.
They took a photo shoot for this shit.
Holy shit.
And then there was hilarious.
You're allowed to feather your hair back
then.
Yeah.
Like check the orleans orleans mercedes,
orleans.
This is important because someone said
to me after I posted the picture of the
old oak ridge boys,
they said they didn't have nothing on
orleans and they put that up and I was
like,
how about homeboy on the right and the
the,
the beer cup on the far left
waking dream and look at this guy
looking down at the other guy's dick.
Literally actually looking down at this
guy's
crazy.
I don't think orleans is doing a show
than fucking each other like each other
during the show.
You just don't notice it.
You don't notice it because there are so
gay.
You blind.
They wash your hair.
Look at this.
This is the far right is calvin and me
had a kid and the kid likes mustaches.
Guys.
Fucking.
Why does he have panty hose around his
neck?
What kInd of clothing is that around?
No,
that's a straight tie.
That's a straight tie.
Don't think it's a tight look.
It's got a task lead with a pink shirt.
You're right.
Damn it.
See seal.
The task lead is to randy coture
stylists tour.
Same style
of randy couture stylists.
They have that little star on the right
because that dude at a boner that's
poking out over the top,
his jeans from high chain,
those are high crocs.
It was like a little broomstick
guys.
The guy that looks like me on the end
here has really arching his back.
He's having a good time and the two guys
in the middle of one of them is the
magician.
The other one is a nature guy.
Damn right.
One looked like a black jack dealer.
The second guy or the far left guy looks
like a guy dies and some sort of crazy
orgy where everybody does too much.
Molly these days,
just having fun back then making music
and sucking dick and I'm not and we're
In shrimp colored shirt jack.
Everyone is so tight these days.
I know,
right?
No fun anymore.
Orleans at anymore.
Could you imagine you have today in
today's climate?
A guy,
but I would've thought that that climate
back then was less tolerant,
super tall as it was back then.
Something,
a national debate going on on whether or
not women should have to go into the
same restroom as transgender people.
That's a national debate.
Who would've ever thought that it would
be this country be so concerned with
hurting people's feelings that that
would be a big part of the national
debate part,
but if a band went out and did that,
we'd be like,
get the fuck out of here with that gay
shit.
It's true.
I would repost tHe obama at the federal
government now asking public schools.
They get public funds to create a
separate bath while.
Okay,
what's going on?
What's going on?
Is this just the internet?
Is it the pressure of of groups on the
internet?
Like what is it about?
I think like anything else for the first
time,
the transgender community has a voice
for the first time.
Anytime you have that,
you're going to be.
You're going to have people that get
very,
very loud and they're.
This is their chance.
This is their moment to say,
hey,
we're here.
We've been in the closet forever and
you're probably going to have the louder
voices in that community and even the
ones that are more extreme drive the
debate.
The problem is that,
you know,
there are concerns for all of us.
For example,
if you identify with a different sex,
if it's really the civil rights act was
all about sex,
right?
But now you're talking about,
now you're talking about discrimination
based on How I perceive myself so I can
be a man and if I put a wig on,
um,
but I say I'm a woman,
I'm identifying with that gender by
federal law,
am I then allow to go into a woman's
bathroom that it becomes difficult.
The problem I have b is like I have to
be cool with everything.
It might be a little weird to me if,
uh,
you know,
there's a dude in a dress I'm not used
to,
that I didn't grow up.
And you're allowed to caItlyn jenner's
on the front of vanity fair or how about
caitlyn jenner now saying I might want
to go back to bruce.
Do you hear that?
No.
Yeah.
So,
so I know you hate that shit joe,
but I'm just saying to me it's a little
weird that she's on the front cover of
sports illustrated.
I'm like,
dude,
I used to be fucking bruce and then I
can hold a homophobe or something like
that because to me it's a little strange
and I can't have questions sums up.
I can't be,
you can't force me to accept you're
right.
But just,
if this is the way to look at it,
in my opinion,
you know,
we,
uh,
we have a lot of different minorities.
Let's just take transgender.
There are sexual minority forever.
they have been relegated to the,
you know,
the shadows.
You had to keep it a secret.
Uh,
you felt different,
etc. Etc.
We know the stories.
Um,
what makes a country strong and great is
the fact that in this country is great
and the difference between this country
and say Russia is Russia has one idea of
what strength is and that is the biggest
muscles and the biggest guns.
And the United States has that too.
But remember,
what makes this countrY strong and
interesting as a culture is the fact
that we create a safe haven for people
who think and act differently.
That's where you get people like marilyn
manson and prince and great artists.
So the debate becomes how do you make
those people feel safe without,
without creating major inconvenience
for,
you know,
the,
the vast majority of the who say we may
not have the funds for a third bath.
I now you're talking about all an entire
different infrastructure.
So how do we work the funds to set up a
electric centers for teslas?
Well,
fuck You.
I,
it's,
it's a good debate to have.
I don't know what the answer was.
I meant to talk to you about the show
about this.
I found the mr han's video.
Well,
let's get back to this because I think
we're done with this.
Um,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Look,
I definitely think that there is a
spectrum of transgender people and I
think there's people that you wouldn't
even notice.
And then there's people that look a lot
like men and one identify with women and
people are going to be scared of that
and there's gonna be weirdness of
involved with that because not because
of the transgender people might be
creepy,
but because we know that there are men
that are predators that are not
transgender men that are straight.
THat's what I care about.
And if you give them the opportunity to
wear a dress and go into the women's
room and just say they identify with
being a woman one what they wanted on
North Carolina.
And this is where it gets interesting is
you had to it.
It's not that you had to be a
transgender person that please someone.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
because I don't think I am.
It's not that you couldn't go in the
bathroom.
If you're a transgender person,
it's you have to go into the bathroom
that matches the gender on your birth
certificate.
Okay.
If you're born a Woman,
but you want to be a man,
you can get that changed on your birth
certificate.
I didn't know that can.
Yeah.
Apparently you can.
Did it so if they do that,
if they get it changed on the,
I don't know how they could change on
your birth certificate 60 years later,
like they do it.
Well,
here's the problem.
We're now we're in this weird semantics
thing where it's.
We're not talking about like technical,
like what,
how,
how fluid is gender.
I mean we're in.
We need to really define this before you
just allow someone to wear a dress.
How someone identifies and it's a very
different.
It's a very different area than the
legislation that exists.
It's cloudy because now you're talking
about you're not talking about male,
female.
You're not saying,
hey,
if you are in the pension plan in this
company,
because women live say 15
years longer or whatever it might be,
you have to pay more into that pension
plan.
As an example.
That was unconstitutional because it was
sex discrimination.
Now these laws are concerned with how
someone identifies.
It's very murky,
so you may have a penis,
but you identify as a woman and you're
taking hormones.
Now we're in a very,
very good.
Here's the brain,
have to be taking hormones.
That's right,
that's just identify with being a woman
to not want to do anything different
than what you are right now and then go
into women's rooms like exception though
joe,
like there's plenty of exceptions.
Well,
because if you can say,
ah,
well guys,
you gonna put on dress and just to go
look at little girls something,
but when.
That'd be the exception overall perhaps.
Yes,
for sure.
Well,
how many transgender people using
bathrooms,
that's the exception.
That's a huge.
Except with the exception to that is
that they're going to go in there just
to look at little girls or molest little
boys.
You're right,
but if it's one out of 100,
it's something we should talk about you.
If it's one out of a can tell you about
it,
but you can't make a decision based on
the accepted but you have to figure out
what it is like.
That's where it gets almost impossible.
You get.
It's really hard to protect women and
children from creepy dudes like,
and this is not a slight on transgenders
at all.
This is talking about transgender.
We're talking about men who are talking
about taking advantage of take advantage
of a law.
That's right.
This has nothing to do with transgenders
giving any possible loophole where a
piece of shit creepy male predator is
allowed to use a bathroom with a 10 year
old girl and under the sanction of the
law.
Yes,
under the sanctions of the law.
I don't know about all that.
I'm not cool with it because when my
daughter steven crowder,
but it's not.
When you're making a law for the
exception,
the first place to make a law that says
that transgender people can use a
woman's room is is an exception.
Okay.
Because you are making a law about a
very rare thing.
A rare thing that when you look at the
entire internet and 7 billion people,
you see millions of examples of it,
so you go,
well,
transgender community is strong.
We should recognize that they're being
discriminated against and that's all
good and I think we all believe that,
right?
We for sure,
but that is a rare thing to make a law
for when you're dealing with how many
women have to use that restaurant.
So do you think.
Hold on a second.
How many women have to use that
restroom,
but wow,
how many,
how many transgenders want to use that
restroom?
Like what are the.
What is the actual numbers that we're
looking at before we start talking about
this and having this goddamn national
debate training new bathrooms created.
Well that might be the only way,
but what are the fucking numbers?
Can we just get some data on the
numbers?
Is there any actual numbers?
It must be.
So then how many men are sexual
predators?
Well,
that's where it gets really fucking
easy.
All you have to do is go to those sexual
predator apps on your iphone.
Everywhere you fucking look.
There's sexual predators now.
It could be a lot of different things.
I know a dude who be got labeled a
sexual predator because he got caught
taking a piss outside.
He went outside,
exposes dick stepped outside of a bar
and pissed.
And because of that,
it is ridiculous,
but it's one of those backwoods country
fuck states and it wasn't like the 19
eighties or something like that.
And this guy got arrested,
took a piss off a porsche,
don't,
don't piss around a playground.
It's not,
not just one guy that's happened to.
This happened to a bunch of guys,
especially if you expose yourself
anywhere near a school or something.
This round elements,
sexual,
sexual predator.
So there's a lot of what we mean by
sexual predator problem is how do you
define.
How do you define what a guy said?
Look,
there's an artIcle that I read the other
day about a guy with a beard.
He has a full beard,
but he identifies as a woman.
He wants to be able to use women's rooms
and he doesn't,
he doesn't take hormones,
but he is a woman.
He feels like he's a woman and he wants
to go.
He doesn't want to have surgery,
but he identifies.
can't have that.
So.
So here's how I feel.
My daughterS.
Hey,
how about that?
I'll tell you,
my daughter's eight.
The other day I had a center into a
public bathroom at the movie theater.
I assume when I send my eight year old
into into a woman's bathroom that she's
going to be safe because it's going to
be little girls and women.
I.
If I say if there's a dude in there with
a beard who says he identifies as a
woman,
I'm not letting my daughter go in that
bathroom until that guy's out of there
and you know why I don't know who that
dude is and he might say he's a.
He identifies as a woman.
He might be fuCking crazy too.
There's also that possibility,
but he's not getting near my daughter
and my whoop your ass.
Yeah.
I also don't trust him.
We'll call it big bearded dude,
man.
I can't say that.
And you,
you know when someone will say that's a
woman and you should say she's a woman.
No,
I would say that's a mega.
Okay,
so when do we draw the line?
Man?
When we draw the line,
where do we draw the line?
Here was,
this was a big part of the fallon fox
debate about found fox becoming a
transgender and then fighting women and
saying she's a woman now.
Yep.
Well with,
with a man's frame.
And then it becomes a sociological or
political issue more than a scientific
and a have a fight analysis,
which is stupid because physically she's
built like a man fighting little girl.
There's a bunch of different reactions
some time that one's easy to make and
then there's also hips,
you know,
the shape of the hips power,
but like toss it aside.
But then again,
what the fuck do you do about someone
like gabby garcia who is clearly taking
male hormones?
Like where does that fit in because
that,
look,
if you're fighting against women and if
you're fighting against women who are
just taking nothing but you're taking
male hormones,
what,
where's this line?
Is it penis,
vagina?
Is that the only line or is there a
certain amount of hormones you take?
Will you become a fucking dude?
And if you look,
if you do it like,
um,
like chastity bono,
chaz bono.
And So she takes the hormones.
She becomes he,
she becomes chaz.
That's male.
Hormones turns into a dude,
right?
We all agree because she says it.
Well,
it's gonna be cursio on more or less
than her.
So I would suggest but more,
but I would suggest that question
becomes relevant only when competition
begins to interfere with your day
routine
rights.
When it,
when it starts getting into situations
where you're going to have to share,
for example,
an example,
public space,
a bathroom,
some something intimate.
That's fight and sport.
FighTing sports.
I love sports.
It's even more in spot.
It's way more important because if gabby
gfsi is on some shit,
she's fighting some poor girl who's just
on,
you know,
the regular protein.
That's why it's illegal to physically
get her accidentally.
It's not illegal,
so I don't legal in Japan.
That's why.
Look,
right?
Yeah.
fallon fox one America.
That's situation.
Toss them aside,
but it's when,
what are we defining gender?
Are we defining it by your own personal
choices?
Do you just decide I'm this.
I feel like a girl would be joanna man,
and I'm going,
wow,
let's talK about this.
I mean,
if you looked at cyborg d this weekend
and she was fighting a leslie smith,
smith,
bless her heart,
you will look at cyborg and she's a
woman of course,
but there is something about her
physicality that clearly she just looks
like she was built to fucking bang on
people's drama.
If you ever seen her first fight.
No,
she didn't look like that.
Okay.
A lot of it is genetically modified.
The.
There's a lot of speculation as to what
she did to in order to look like that,
but she's also one thing.
Here's one thing,
undeniable.
That woman works hard.
She runs six miles everyday.
She trains like A fucking beast.
Yes.
Apparently according to her trainers,
she has an insane work rate.
Right.
But she definitely is tested positive
for something.
She's does pause,
but also now she is in the ufc and I
don't know.
We don't know.
I'm not saying she's taking shit.
We got to wait until the drug results
come back in Brazil,
this past fight,
but at 1:40 1:35,
she's by far the best female fighter in
the ufc until you beat her.
You Ain't shit dude.
The way she ran punch your leslie smith
face technique is flawless.
This is,
but the credit has to go to jason
parillo,
who's her boxing coach because at her
level she's been doing it forever,
right?
To take a fighter that has that many
fights and to give them this set of
skills.
Now,
because notice this is what was most
impressive to me in that fight.
She didn't get hit right.
She had head movement,
foot work angles.
She didn't get hit.
Cyborg gets hit.
When she fights,
she'll trade sit bang Mike Tyson style.
She had footwork.
Lindsey smith,
atlanta,
a single punch.
I see that one.
Oh shit.
Perillo should begin all the credit and
also perilla work and granted I've,
I've,
I've never worked with pearl,
nothing.
I'm just analyzing his fighters with
brisbane to bisping box.
Anderson silva's face off a box and
clinic.
I don't know if you could shake like
that and save face.
I mean,
he didn't just drop.
I was trying to exaggerate.
The point did drop.
He dropped him,
but he also landed the most shots ever.
An interest in civil.
Again,
a veteran fighter in brisbane who's been
fighting forever.
What's the one common denominator before
I forget,
coach,
do you
think it was dirty when anderson jumping
kneed him in the face or do you think
that michael bisping's not supposed to
call for a resets on his mouth?
Bisbing before every fight.
Herb dean or big john count.
Go,
listen,
man.
Protect yourself at all times.
Don't stop unless I come in and stop.
We all know that,
but he's trying to say my mouthpiece.
He's talking to the ref and the in,
wouldn't you think?
Would you.
Would you agree like when is there a
break in the action?
Technically if a guy's talk to the
referee and he's moving away and he's
not an exchange,
it's like,
hey,
I'll drop my mouth.
Just dropped my mouthpiece.
Is that a break in the action or is he
calling for a break in the action and it
could be perceived these calling for a
break in the action because the momentum
is not shifting his way.
Correct.
look,
I can't stop until I was like,
dude,
I'm.
I'm fighting to the death until that's a
bad term.
There,
but until a ref tells me not right on
man,
so like when I hit cro,
cop,
that's on herb dean step step your 40
time up son.
Okay,
but should he be allowed to stop to see
the break in the action things
ambiguous.
Here's my thought.
If you move back,
move back and you put your hands up and
you go my mouthpiece and you put your
hands up,
you're calling for a break in the action
and the referee says that's not your
place.
Your place is to compete.
Which is correct.
Or do theY have to wait to an actual
break in the action?
I think they have to wait for an actual
break,
but why is that?
Because you should be.
You should not be able to fight.
Look,
you should definitely be penalized.
Like did you see when simon mark has
fought joe schilling kept spitting out
mouthpiece so they took a point away
from them because they.
They thought because he kept spitting it
out that he was tired and was trying to
take a break,
which is what he was doing.
Some guys do do that so that in order to
stop that from happening,
they penalize you,
veterans,
but referee,
if he knows that your mouthpiece is out,
he should have stopped the fight.
So it's real.
It's real tricky.
Like just the referee after what?
Because you really find me looking at
something else though.
Right?
You really shouldn't be able to see.
the problem is like lips and gums with
teeth,
with raw teeth.
your face getting fucked up.
Man.
It's been an interesting.
We're kind of in it.
It was like it was kinda hit it and it
came out and he's like,
no,
no.
Stop.
YeaH.
He was like,
why?
He pointed at his mouthpiece low.
Remember when Paul Harris with nate,
mark core turned the ref and said,
hey,
he's got stick.
He's got slippery stuff on his ankle and
nate just dove in and my bow bow bow
that that's got to be on the fighter who
voluntarily unilaterally take salsa.
Not.
I mean it's not dirty.
It's not dirty because that's a fighter
dude.
It's a very dangerous sport.
I see any glimpse where I can get an
advantage.
I'm fucking like floyd mayweather and
victor ortiz.
I have no problem with that.
Was that to me was fucked up.
It's no,
it's a fight.
He came up and said,
heY man,
sorry.
I already said sorry twice.
And he goes,
come on.
Oh,
that's bullshit.
Bullshit.
Look,
I'll tell you what.
It was victorious.
He's at a mental breakdown.
He was succumbing to the pressure.
He was fouling a floyd,
had this head butting him and he got
penalized for it when it got penalized
for it.
He wanted to make friends with floyd and
in the making friends part like,
I'm sorry bro.
Look,
a lot of times you can't have that in a
fight.
You can't that in flight because the
disruption
of your focus,
it's adding in this emotional connection
with this person.
Now this person's your buddy.
Okay,
we're bros were bros,
right?
Let's go back to fighting for like,
fuck you.
Lap righthand.
Cota Sleep is known for that
got knocked out by berto.
Cold blooded.
Yeah,
man,
I think he's done right.
He,
it seems like should be.
I think like it seems like when he got
really famous and things started taking
off,
like he didn't,
he did dancing with the stars.
Movies.
YeaH.
The expendables.
Doing well against berto.
The first five rounds like shit here.
He,
because you remember they built him up
as the next oscar de la hoya.
He was like the golden boy and then it
just never worked out.
Two fights I want to see as golovkin
canelo and I want to say a kovalev andre
ward.
Kovalev and andrea award is going to be
crazy.
That's happening for sure.
Yeah.
That's happening.
I can't wait for andre.
Ward is so smart.
He just has to fight more.
He's so smart,
but that might not be enough.
Might not be enough against koval other
meds so hard.
Well he's not so skillful is fuck
killed.
The guy killed his father at all.
Killer.
no.
Doesn't give a fuck about,
uh,
and it's kinda stupid talking about.
But it has legs.
Floyd mayweather.
conor mcgregor,
you.
and if we know,
we know doesn't have any legs.
It kinda does.
It does.
You know why?
Because floyd ones,
it doesn't matter.
New ufc is not gonna let it happen.
Well,
but see,
tHe only reason why I disagree with you
there is because dana goes in.
Floyd wants to make that fight happened.
Call me.
Dana is a businessman.
They care about money.
You know big.
That fight would be,
how much money do you think they could
make if floyd mayweather fights conor
mcgregor biggest biggest paper of all
time?
No,
you don't think so?
What's of yet?
It might be
the biggest draw already in ufc mma
made,
whether it's the biggest paper,
you draw a box and ball time.
You mixed the world.
Everyone would tune in including your
dad.
I would you tell them you wouldn't do an
end now because you're so full of.
Should very unInteresting taken two hits
instead of the little baby face.
If I know it's.
It's fascinating.
This spark joy.
So.
So what would happen is floyd mayweather
would box with conor mcgregor and
basically move around and be like,
all right,
here,
god's going to be a spectacle.
It's just not a fight.
It wouldn't be a fight where you were
fucking party pooper.
Yes.
And then our cheer.
This is the thing you gotta remember the
one thing that dana and floyd mayweather
who would be responsible in this fight
together and connor,
for that matter,
all they care about is money and
numbers.
That fight would be money and fucKing
It would break.
Pack you all made with the kennedy.
okay.
I know,
but what I'm saying is that how would,
how would they,
how would that fight come?
What would they do in that fight?
So floyd probably can knock them out
anytime he wanted,
right?
No,
no.
Connor has a very good chin.
I mean kinda got knocked up by nate diaz
or he got knocked down and hurt and
wobbled by nate diaz.
Yeah.
Little gloves.
first of all,
native.
ReallY good puncher needs a big guy,
a nate.
Nate's fought at one 70.
He's a lot bigger than floyd,
like physically alive.
but floyd is a guy who's broken his
hands many,
many times and he's not known for really
uncorking all of his might and trying to
knock it down,
knock out artists in the least bit.
But he could,
he certainly could.
You know,
it's not.
The floor doesn't hit real hard,
but when you box real smart knockouts
come,
the opportunity comes like the ricky
hatton fight.
That'S a perfect example.
That knockout came.
Yep.
It sound like he went looking for the
victor or five.
Victor just fucked up and he just left
hook right hand.
Um,
and he was,
he was a total sucker punch.
Like you had no idea what was going on
with it.
Has issues of scale,
like madonna.
I mean if you suggest the first fight he
box the shit out of them did.
But it may dilute,
like if,
if,
if I was college coaching that fight
were to happen,
I'm like,
hey man,
don't be pretty thin on the outside and
hit this guy.
We make this a dogfight.
You're the bigger guy.
You think connor would actually give
floyd mayweather a boxing match?
Is tHat what I'm hearing?
No,
that's not what anybody's saying.
this is the thing we're saying that he's
the biggest straw and saying that I
don't think floyd would juSt go out and
try to knock them out in the box.
I think you Would canelo alvarez them,
but key obviously canelo's way more
skillful in boxing.
Yeah,
I mean canelo is a world champion.
One punch knockout artists,
boxer.
I mean that fucking amir khan knockout.
Hey jesus.
Louise's,
you know,
was a super fucking home run on the
button.
Dude,
floyd got hit.
He said after he got.
When he fought canelo he got punched in
the thigh by canelo had trouble walking
for two days.
He literally,
he didn't show it after the fight.
He was like,
dude,
my thigh.
He punched me in the thigh so hard.
I,
I am having trouble walking that to
live.
Lloyd is never going to fight mma
because if connor would fucking break
his legs like literally mma be.
It would be more embarraSsing than tonic
doing just box.
He would get way more embarrassing
because is a big guy.
Employed would have to like box smart
alec connor.
I think kinda would have just
unbelievably difficult time even coming
close to hitting him.
I man,
I think he's gonna straight boxing with
grazing stuff.
He's probably.
You're Talking about if not the greatest
boxer of all time and his defense is
good.
It would be a great show.
It's a good.
It'd be the best defense ever for sure.
Who's on the fence in floyd and now
you're taking a guy who he's an elite
strike in the ufc but boxing's a
different game.
Man.
You know,
I would.
Would've loved to seen canelo fight
floyd like in a couple of years when
canelo's like 27,
28 when he has the experience because I
think like if you look at like sugar ray
leonard versus roberto duran,
like both guys were like really in their
prime experience world in big.
You know what I mean?
Sometimes like your prime comes early,
like tyson and sometimes you prime comes
later,
you know bernard hopkins.
But when a guy's in his prime,
he know he's in his prime.
I think canelo wasn't in his prime when
he fought for.
I think I still don't.
I think he's getting there and if I'm
canelo's management and as a fan I won't
see canelo triple g and greg,
they say canal is probably gonna have to
vacate and his belt.
If he doesn't fight triple g,
that's what they're saying.
But that.
Wait,
why does he want 1:55 that's not
middleweight.
Like why are they sending it?
Is making all these fights at 1:55 and
they're calling a middleweight because
it's over 1:54.
Yeah.
They have a weird thing going on.
That's what's wrong with boxing.
But if i'M canelo's camp,
I'm not sending that fight up yet.
Man.
As a fan I'm like,
dear god,
make that fight happened.
He a businessman,
a manager.
I'm like,
canola,
you ain't find triple g right now.
We don't do a couple more big paydays
and because also you gotta remember
triple g's not a draw.
We know him.
We're in the fight.
He's not a draw at all.
His paper you did I think 125,000.
175,000 and then listen,
big drama show big drama drama show soon
as the belt series business.
That guy,
he's awesome,
but he's not,
he's just not like a,
as far as being a paper view,
drawing power.
He's not there yet.
So the new 30 and knock him the fuck
out.
He won't do it.
You toss canelo like lemieux or someone
else so you can just merch and keep
building his name.
well he wants to go.
Uh,
he wanted to be one 60 and canelo wants
it to be 1:55.
Apparently that's a hold up.
And you know,
he triples.
He's a bigger guy.
If triple g has,
she dropped down five pounds,
they think it'll be enough to weaken
them.
And you know,
maybe canelo can have a chance and they
can slug it out in the trenches.
But If you look at the fight,
the actual fight itself,
when amir khan just fought canelo,
he did expose that speed and movement
are still a problem.
Yes.
It just,
he doesn't have the same speed or the
same movement.
It's floyd,
but his speed and movement were a bit of
a problem.
You have some real issues,
some real estate to his landing all
night.
Yes.
Especially in the first round.
The first round he lit him up with some
straight right hand.
So that was like,
ooo,
okay,
how's this gonna play out?
But I think that there is no one else in
that division that can do that.
Photo couldn't do it to him.
Canelo outbox codo mean.
Um,
and then floyd was really the only guy
to expose it.
But floyd floyd,
there's no other floyd's yeah.
So who the fuck else is in the division?
But I think triple g canelo right now is
that it'd be a bad decision for canelo
will terrence crawford is 1:47,
so talented 1:47 and one slash four and
next door neighbors my.
OH,
here it is.
They fight over like two and three
pounds.
It's crazy.
I can make the weight different than mma
in that regard.
So weird mma,
you're dealing with a middle way to
light heavyweight,
which guys jumped back and forth.
You dealing with 20 fucking pounds.
I mean,
that's madness.
Be more away classes.
Yeah.
I've been saying this from the jump.
There should be a weight class every 10
pounds and they're like,
well,
if there's too many champions in waters
down,
I completely disagree.
You're telling me some of these amazing
fighters that you have that are
superstars like a donald cerrone,
like a diego sanchez,
like all these different guys,
so it was just so amazing.
Guys.
I've never won a title that are huge
favorites,
right?
If you look at all these different guys,
uriah favors and other ones you're
telling me those guys couldn't have been
champions and you wouldn't have had even
more champions and an even crazier thing
if there were.
If there was a weight class every teN
pounds and a better product a better.
You're getting better performances from
because donald's not destroying his body
to make 55.
You're not having these monsters make
these weight classes and the actual
world champions.
There's sponsorships.
So enough weight classes.
There's classes two.
Oh,
six,
two,
two 65.
How dare you?
It's crazy.
It's crazy,
right?
Tim?
It too,
but what's interesting is the best guys
seem to like flatten out around 2:42.
so my thought is let's make a to 40,
let's make that heavyweight and then two
and a half to two to 40 to 65 or a
little champions.
The better.
All the way up.
The only time you Can't.
It's like a little bit of a problem.
A problem is with cyborg,
right?
Because she's like,
she goes,
I'll fight anyone at 1:40,
but at one forties have I heard from my
source?
It was a beast for it to get to.
I think she's the 1:45 pound invicta
champion.
They have a 1:35 in the ufc 1:45 and I
think you can do 1:40 5:40.
Why?
But why do it?
Why maker make it?
She's a 1:45 pound champ.
I know,
but there's not a lot of all the
superstars on 1:35 can make 1:40 to make
them put on 10 pounds.
Ever build it.
They will come have right now mr rogen
right now.
You understand she's the invicta
champion,
so she's fighting people in invicta.
Hey,
yeah,
look,
it's true.
She's better than all of them anyway.
It doesn't matter,
but you shouldn't be forcing her to kill
herself.
When 1:45 is already established.
Weight class.
Misha tate was the 1:45 pound champion.
Strikeforce.
It's good point.
Established way that you would fight or
two.
It's an established weight class,
I think at 1:40 though.
Well listen,
holly homes for people in boxing as high
as 1:52.
It's 1:45 and established weight class
to sign up the house.
How doeS holly holm do cyborg?
A holly holm as his.
She has the best chance because cyborg
is a ruthless marauder.
She's berserker a tower.
Shoot the box style.
Not this last night.
No,
she wasn't this last site.
Who will and those hits.
I was like,
oh shit.
That counter that counter right hands
now.
So let's fix these card.
Nice hard core.
She's mad at thomas.
She's a beast.
She should.
She should definitely thanked the
referee.
The referee saved her from herself.
Yes,
but she's just so tough fighter.
She's so tough that you want.
She wanted to go out on our shield.
Yeah.
She was already gone.
She doesn't understand ground and pound.
That shit is ill fate or days.
She was punching him in the face.
She's so much more advanced than anybody
else creates so much more to perillo.
Well,
she's different than holly.
Completely.
Holly is a counter striker and holly
also had a really brutal knockout in
boxing against a larger woman and have
watched it.
I was like,
whoa.
It's the kind of knockout that you never
really fight that way again because you
realize the consequences now and like
someone gets brutally,
brutally knocked out there,
aware of that as a consequence and I
think she's become much more of a
defensive minded counter striker,
which was super effective against ronda
better I think for her.
Right.
But it didn't look so good against misha
because misha was fighting super smart,
but it was also.
Well,
it's also because misha doesn't rush
after all your anxiety on the outside
flat.
Amazing.
But I also thought for whatever reason
holly didn't fight like herself.
She doesn't like was it pulling the
trigger?
She doesn't like to lead to lead and
she's worried about being taken down.
Once she got taken down by me shaLl we
realized why she doesn't like to lead
me,
should took her down,
beat the shit out of her on the ground,
like destroyed her in that second round
was on top of or most of the round just
beating her ass.
And so we knew,
look of me,
she gets her down,
she's fucked.
So then she fights like a,
like a craftsman to the third and fourth
round.
She just fights real smart,
stays on the outside edges,
those rounds.
And then she's forced to go for broke
and the fifth and mission wound up
taking her out and choking.
Right story,
man.
So,
but Here's the thing.
cyborgs way better on the ground.
I mean way better on the ground and
strong.
Way better way,
way better.
Way better.
Cyborg wind,
straight jujitsu competitions.
She is fucking strong.
Your fucking face.
Suplexes she just made she dahlan bitch
and she gets on top of you.
Oh my god.
Her grounded pound.
it looks like a panther,
like she looks like.
It's almost like she was put on earth
for one thing.
Well,
when she's in that ring,
that cage,
you're just doing shit to.
You beat her.
Yeah.
She's.
She's built herself into that.
It's taken so long for her to finally
get her.
Now she's here and everyone's like,
god,
even when she's here,
man,
they.
They did it in Brazil.
They did it at 1:42.
They made her suffer.
I would have my personal choice.
I would have had the first ever 145
pound fight in the ufc.
Led a bunch of people sign up to be who
wants to.
Who wants to get in there and my man the
price.
But I think you've got invicta girls
that are agreeing to fight her.
So if you've got invicta,
girls are agreeing to fight.
Are you telling me those girls wouldn't
take a fight in the ufc?
Of course I'm telling you,
no one would care.
Frank get.
Doesn't matter.
It's the cyborg show.
Do it.
It's the sideboard show right now.
This is Mike Tyson versus people that
you don't know and you know it's turning
tubs.
Mike tyson versus tony tops.
She has a ways to go where she's Mike
Tyson.
She just got introduced to when you went
to see Mike Tyson versus tony tubs.
Didn't think tony tubs.
Gonna win a tony thompson.
You went to see the Mike Tyson shot?
No,
I was there to see tony title.
If you're me,
shows manager and they're like,
hey,
we need you to find at 1:45 sidebar.
Take me.
Show me.
I think mishi would take that shit and
take it,
but no one else like that in a good move
that dope and listen,
you know,
cyborg.
Like,
go back to the gina carano fight.
Cyborg had problems in that fight so
people don't understand.
Gina carano had her mounted.
Giancana was a tough fucking girl.
They duked it out.
Gina literally was on top of her head
are mounted.
Cyborg wasn't the same sideboard back
then,
but sidebar was way more shredded back
then.
She was,
she was like a bodybuilder man.
She's terrifying.
Like just the physical muscular,
the muscularity and the power that she
had.
There's a picture that I'll never
forget,
man,
is one of,
if I have like a list of all my iconic
memories of phoTographs in mma,
there'S one where cyborg is grabbing the
head of gina carano.
She's got her fingers out,
she's got an mma glove on with nail
polish on,
and she's about to punch her in the face
and gina's phases already fucked up and
cyborgs holding her head and she's about
to.
There it is right there.
Look at that.
Come on son.
that is an iconic photo.
Look at the eyes,
the cold blooded killers in the
background.
It shows up.
Boom.
She's asleep and robbing a right hand on
her.
Fucking crushing her.
Feel that bitch.
Yeah,
and this is by the way,
the cyborg Washington,
but look at the muscles on her fucking
shoulder and your arm and the cyborg
you're looking at today.
The cyborg.
You look at it to say,
what the fuck this cyborg up for sure,
and she's better now.
She's,
she's fucking dedicated,
man.
I'm just doing the damn thing ever seen
some of the videos of her training at a
paquette top team?
Nope.
Taking good lord.
She spends a lot of time at Thailand
running hills and training with men.
I saw the,
uh,
the,
her man,
the old man.
And what?
This cyborg santos fight and bella tour
this past week.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He,
well,
he,
he commit to bars.
Weird snatcher because he won in the
first fight with a knee bar.
Yeah.
So this time he committed to it and it's
gonna hit them like for sure let go.
Then he bar for sure,
like it was too late.
There's a picture of her and him,
her husband and her.
Oh.
They have their backs,
their backs and her back is every bit as
well.
They have one way to ask this and it's
both of them just like.
That's unfortunate.
Is that picture where you see it?
No,
it's awesome.
Friends talked them out of those kind of
photo.
I disagree.
It's like the brazilian colona
colona
boom by,
but I think it's boom by a bom.
Dia.
No.
How about matt brown could have gotten
any worse?
I didn't say it.
My fucking my goddamn dvr fucked up.
Somehow my kids put like max and ruby on
or some shit,
you know,
like,
like sometimes people try to have two
things being taped.
It stops.
My wife will move up.
The kid shows to the top of the order.
So I didn't,
I didn't even watch this.
So he gets fucked up by the fans and
they kicked this fan out by the way,
the fifth punched him in the face
because he's flipping everyone off weigh
ins.
And then his old coach after the fight,
he was in their head,
man.
They got mad.
A couple guys smacked him in the head
they took.
They took that dude out of the arena
though.
Yeah.
But a couple of guys smacked him in the
head as he's running in before the guy
punched him.
I'm saying they took one of the guys out
to smack them.
Oh,
did they really should have taken all of
them.
I agree.
Stupid.
Hey security.
Step your fucking game up.
But it's Just,
it's embarrassing.
Oh shucks.
Someone though.
Oh yeah.
Dude,
he uncorked a bomb on someone's face.
Damien maia,
matt brown in the face.
Damien maia said,
welcome to my country about to choke.
So I love to see the fight.
Man.
Can you.
Can we find the fight?
Jamie?
See if you can find the fight.
So what?
We'll do commentary,
but how bout how bout afterwards?
He's in the hotel and his old coach
sucker punched in back of the head.
That's what I heard.
And then got his old coaches,
old brown brown's old grappling punch
sucker.
Punched him back in the head and then he
runs off.
Oh no,
you ain't running because matt brennan's
coaches around.
Lisa bowling is other coach.
They catch this dude beat the brakes off
of him and got arrested.
Read harris was just like,
hey,
just went all aggro.
Caught the studio.
Why they punched him in the back of the
head?
Because they have a history.
What an asshole.
Yeah,
but can you get a p on my big huge dick?
I'll be right back.
Let us know about it.
Thinking about
he's all trimmed up,
huh?
Okay.
How much does he lost?
I swear to god.
He's got to be usually walked around at
2:55 and every bit he's probably to 40
right now.
Has it made you think about changing
your diet now?
You like eating bread and shit?
Yeah,
I do well with carbs like rice and eat
pretty clean rice.
Potatoes.
I don't,
I don't mind it.
I,
I don't think I'm the body type.
I think I'd get even skinnier.
Dude,
I,
you know,
for me I need all the carbs I can get.
I sleep well on carbs.
Have you ever tried not having them?
No.
So how do you know?
No,
I mean I have though.
Actually that's not true.
I don't,
I,
I stay very far away from sugar to them,
but that's I think the most important
thing to sugar.
That's what I was telling people when I
moved the first attempt at doing
something.
I went,
I tried gluten,
no gluten,
but I think the real issue is I wasn't
eating bread,
so if I'm eating bread I'm not getting
sugar.
Exactly.
And when I,
and I don't eat a lot of bread because
I'm aware of because I monitor my body
like so if I eat two slices,
even if really good bread,
I notice that my energy kind of.
It's not the same as if I eat slow
cooked oatmeal,
I feel really good.
Right?
Yeah.
There's definitely some spikes going on.
Insulin spikes going on when you eat
sugar and you eat bread and we're just
used to them.
Remember I only eat a lot either.
That's the other thing.
Like I don't,
I'm not a big deal.
We got to fight and here it is.
Damien maia and matt brown.
This is around three.
Okay.
We don't know what was going on before
that,
but we assume it was good.
They don't look too sprawling.
He's trying to.
He's trying to keep it standing up with
damien.
Maia is doing a good job of standing on
the outside of,
but he's making it a real obvious that
he wants to take them down and shoots in
as move away from the
keck.
He's so big at one 70.
My miles a beast at one 70.
I never seen him in person.
I mean you fought for the title at one
85.
Who's a big guy.
Whoo.
Good job there by mine and he tries to
take down again.
Matt brown punches him and matt brown
gets on top.
This is where you fucked up,
man.
Can't do that dude.
That's a trap.
You trap you.
We thought he heard them.
You know he didn't really hurt him.
Damien maia did exactly.
Britain shop just returns.
He did exactly what we were saying about
for breach over dealing with fader.
He pretends he gets hurt and matt brown
moved in to try to finish them.
And then maya got ahold of him in my
drag them to the ground.
This is how confident he is in his
jujitsu.
He lets him mount him.
I mean he drags him to the ground just
to do this,
just to sweep them.
And now matt brown,
that sequence,
that whole sequence was so advanced.
What he just did theRe,
he let matt brown drag him down in matt
brown.
His instincts is a destroyer.
Were to immeDiately get on top of him
because he's not seen that in training.
No one's done training.
No.
Especially not allowing him to
potentially knock them out with some
ground and pound,
but damien maia is jujitsu is so solid
and so slick that whatever shot
attempts,
he gets off mostly a deflected and then
eventually sweeps him and now he's
mounting up against the cage and matt
brown right now is in quicksand.
When you have damien maia on top of you
and your legs are pinned together like
that.
That's a terrifying because what he's
done here is he's isolated his legs with
a triangle.
So by having those legs extended like
that,
he has no power from his hips.
He can't throw any punches,
he can't get his feet back under them
and can't get those legs back.
So he's got to commit with his hands.
So he's got to push down with his hands
and while he's pushing down his hands,
mike and punch him in the face.
And so finally he gets his half guard
back up.
But whatever.
Good luck with that butterfly.
He'll get these butterflies,
a mild.
We'll just sit on your legs and wear
them out,
put pressure on you,
and then when you stand up and just get
to an even better position.
This for all three rounds by the.
Well,
this is what he does,
man.
He did it to rick story.
Rick story is a real law.
He's a gorilla wrestler who walks around
a 200 cuts down to one 70 and demian
maia ragdoll.
That wasn't that precedent.
He did it to gunner nelson and then neil
magnums like,
oh,
you're on a winning streak.
That's cool.
Check this out.
Jake shields beat damien maia grappling
contest will create eight.
Shields is legit.
One of the best in the world and as a
grappler,
one of the best in the world.
I beat him in the ufc.
Yeah,
I mean,
but that's my grappling.
Yeah,
because if they were grappling,
jake would give him a hell of a fucking
run.
Jake is a base dude.
His grappling is absolutely world class.
Oh yeah.
His problem in the ufc,
he's always been a speed and the
striking.
He's just not a dangerous striker in the
way a lot of guys are.
It's not even that he's a born fighter,
well,
not to me,
to the breast.
So you look at you look at who he's
been.
This he's beat the very best.
He's beat I think top five guys.
He's beat robbie lawler.
Look at all these guys.
Damien maia,
hey,
you had this.
He's trying.
He's trying to protect himself,
but it's just few tile.
It's just when maya gets that body
triangle round on you,
he's just constantly manipulating you.
He doesn't try and one direction only
like he is setting up escape doors.
So if you try to move through one of
those escape doors,
a new trap is waiting for you and those
traps you're not going to see because
from years and years and years of
jujitsu,
so your basic movements that usually get
you out.
It happen right in the face.
Over and over.
Yeah.
I don't say,
hey,
well let me ask you this.
You would know this.
Why?
WHen they showed the top contenders in
185 pound weight class was yoel romero
not there because he's just got clear
because he just got.
Well,
he didn't get cleared to fight again.
He,
they cleared the possibility that he
might get a lesser sentence because they
found that supplement that he took,
but you're not supposed to take
supplements when you just buy some shit
at gnc.
He's just beat.
Mine has just beaten on them and
manipulating them with that body
triangle man.
crazy.
Because there is not clear.
I thought it was clear to fight.
No,
no,
I don't think they've made a clear
decision yet.
But they've opened the door for him with
that.
Oh my god.
He tried to punch back behind him.
That's.
I'm surprised you did that.
Well,
he's done exactly once.
It's under the neck.
No,
this one.
This one's over.
There's not much bad ass.
Is matt brown though?
Oh my god.
He's bad ass.
But I'm Just so impressed with damien
maia mean.
How do you not be impressed with damien?
My title shot next.
Fuck yeah.
Was by the western through all these
young kids.
Those guys down there all fucked.
They're all fucked.
Damien maia.
If you don't knock him out and at one 70
that ain't no picnic because he can
strike.
You can hit hard man.
Well,
if you decide to strike with robbie
lawler.
Kidding.
I don't think he will.
I mean,
He's gonna.
Try to turn them into one of these.
I agree dude.
He's the master when it comes to
jujitsu.
He is the ufc master because he is at
all of the guys.
He's the one guy that's fought the most
intelligently with jujitsu because look
it for brief ceo.
His striking got better.
He got better with striking,
striking ultimately cost him.
Yes.
Whereas my,
uh,
is just never gone off track.
He used to pee.
This is new though.
This new winning streak.
Because remember before.
Yeah.
When.
Yeah,
when you went down to one 71 85 years
trying to strike.
We can do too much.
It was too small.
He wasn't strong enough to overwhelm
them at one slash 70 but,
or I want 85 but it won 70.
He is going to be tough to beat man.
I want to see.
I'm excited to see a fight.
A look.
Yeah.
Speaking of jujitsu.
Well,
luke's got to get past weidman.
No,
the rematch with weidman is going to be
crazy.
Interesting.
Look,
weidman made a big mistake in that fight
before that big mistake,
which was yes,
it was a very close fight.
It was like,
who knows what was going on and now
weidman says he had a broken foot,
but luke said he had a bad staph
infection.
You know more than anybody when you go
into fights most of the time you're not
100 percent,
100 percent.
And with with weidman,
from what I hear from this campaign from
him is it was the worst camp of his
life.
Like he knew he needed to change things,
but he thought he was so talented as
real champions.
Fine.
Didn't even do anything.
Why was it the worst camp?
I guess he had injuries and certain
things like he should have been flying
people in and he just didn't in a.
He should have been going somewhere
else.
Was working with Mark Henry Moore and
doing other stuff and he's just a good
man.
I'm chant and it kind of got comfortable
and it ended up costing them.
This is no,
this is no gimme fight for either god or
either guy.
This is a great fight.
This is a war,
a war,
you know?
I mean rockhold thinks he's going to run
through them this time because he thinks
he doesn't have a staph infection and
you know,
the staph infection was physically like
really bad and he thinks he also is
rotting on the confidence of having pete
and ham having beaten the living fuck
out of leo machida.
His top game is some of the nastiest
shit I've ever seen in my life.
So good dude.
That's what happens.
He's a big dude,
but he's also really talented.
Really smart,
works hard and he trains with two
fucking cain velasquez and danny,
so he's going to waR with gorillas and
time.
Habib habib,
I think training with a guy that's as
high level as habib.
You miRror some of his movements,
you,
you understand what he's doing.
And then habib's dad down there helping
guys out there.
A data coach.
Oh,
he.
His dad coached habib.
You know what I mean?
His dad's always around at bb and his
dad coached a few other guys that fought
in the ufc as well,
but you're also getting from habib and
dc and cane.
You also Picking up their training
tendencies of the blueprint of these
elite of the elite and three of them and
the four of them are coming together and
cook too.
Man.
Bob cook's a wizard.
Javier mendez is a wizard mean you got.
You got great talent as far as coaching.
They're all.
They all have fights coming up.
They're all together.
He's also about as big as you can get
for an 85 or like he walked around.
He was trying to choose 16.
You know,
like that's a big guy,
you know,
that's a lot of ways.
He's,
he's slim right now.
He's in shape right now.
I just saw him this weekend.
He's slim while he's fighting in a
couple of weeks.
he was fighting for two weeks before he
was 215 pounds here.
It's out here now.
Late June 4th is June 4th,
June 3rd and fourth.
Yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
That weekend.
That's a,
that's a big,
big fight in the middleweight division.
It's not getting enough attention,
man.
It's interesting.
Who becomes huge and famous and who does
not become huge and famous.
It's really interesting,
but I don't see.
I haven't seen much publicity on this
fight either.
I haven't.
Zero.
No.
I mean I'm sure they're going to ramp it
up when it comes close to a paper view
time,
but as far as like the history of the
middle weight division,
I mean anderson was the goat,
right?
He's the greatest of all time.
Anderson loses to this kid named weidman
by knockout.
Weidman should become.
Star doesn't work like that.
I mean,
he's a star.
I don't.
I don't understand that.
That sounds so good in my eyes.
I don't understand.
As a fan of MMA,
I immediately became a gigantic chris
weidman fan.
I was already a chris weidman fan.
Here's,
here's the scary shit on that fucking
card.
Hector lombard versus dan henderson.
Jesus christ.
Do not blink.
Don't blink and don't count that old man
out.
You can never can't
count that guy if he,
if he comes to the gun with a scarf on,
I'm counting them out.
See ya.
Clay is fighting again.
Cole miller fight and bj penn.
Whoa.
Here's one.
Someone's.
Everyone's sleeping on.
Max holloway.
Get on bus fighting.
Ricardo lamas.
Click on that.
Everybody's sleeping on that.
Actually bro,
take plague.
Play as a.
Because greta is going to try and take
him down there.
That's good luck with all that.
Take us.
Transition is his guard is I think the
best in that division of about 45.
I think it's the best in the ufc that
nobody fucking throws up triangles the
way brian or taken does.
That guy is so scary off his back.
Got to train.
When that guy joe,
it's.
I'm sure it's like what up?
Just google.
Oh,
and all he does is let people the best
in the world.
star and is go.
You just tRained from there all the
time.
I didn't know everything so fast and
explosive.
He's athletic.
I completely believe it.
He got popped.
He did.
He got popped for something to pop those
black boys to him for awhile there.
Yeah,
he got popped for something back.
But let me tell you something.
His last performance.
Click on him real quick.
Let me see what his last fight was.
I forget what his.
Um,
who triangle city.
Yeah.
Well that's his tc is,
is one by to last fight.
He did.
That's his nickname.
Triangle city.
Diego brando.
Brando.
Yeah.
Because then reimburse your thing.
I bet you're thinking of the fight.
Whereas back and forth from here that
that was the third round fight of the
night.
And then it was.
Yeah,
it was the diego brandao fight.
That's what it is.
And randall said,
you know what man,
I'm going to go to strip clubs with a
gun.
You see how this works out?
Then use said,
hey man,
you're not John Jones.
We're going to fletcher.
go bless you.
Go to a strip club with a gun idea.
Bad idea or impulse control.
Now I'm remembering the fight.
It was super,
super impressive.
That plagues weedo or tayga one.
That's fun.
When they told me you got that match up,
I said this the perfect fight for you
because the big name,
it's a great style match up for you and
everyone loves clay and it puts you more
in the map.
You know clay,
what's he?
Where's he at now?
Is he's still trying to.
jackson's or jackson muscle farm.
He's like in his rv and shit.
Driving around nonstop.
It's been awhile since he said a good.
When I agree.
You gotta wonder how much longer he's
going to be doing this.
I agreement.
So this could be a make or break fight
for him,
but if he wins,
who knows?
Resurgence after cruz favor with three,
right?
Yup.
I'm just not excited for it.
Why?
I don't know.
Why are you out of your mind knowing
that weird.
Oh my god.
Can you cite for maybe I'd love this
fight.
I love this fight because first of all,
I think uriah faber is as close as you
can get to being a world champion.
Goddamn me.
He's on the edge.
Like everybody.
He fights.
Like if he loses to like a world
champion,
it's like a whisper thin decision close
or the one fight that he had with hanan
barao he got cracked and that was a
weird stoppage man as like he definitely
got cracked and if hanan barao cracks
you got fucking problems.
But I thought the stop,
which was a little weird,
but anybody can get cracked like that.
Anybody can lose like that.
That's just a part of this game.
But I think if you look at talent level
and skill level,
I go back to like the Michael Macdonald
fight when he fucking just blitzkrieg
dumb and smashed him.
Donaldson just came back recently,
came back recently and one looked
fantastic.
Looked good.
Yeah.
But that fight was kinda like,
you know what?
Yeah,
I'm going to take a little break.
But when uriah beat them,
uh,
it really cemented in my hand.
I was like,
look,
you got to never sleep on this kid.
He's never that.
You can't man.
He's one of the biggest draws to.
He's super competitive and I think he's
better.
I think he keeps getting better.
I don't think he's a guy that's in a
static state.
No,
I don't think he's like a veteran that's
kind of like,
you know,
just putting in the work and phoning it
in.
I don't think so.
Just gets in shape.
Brings us new.
Normal.
I don't think so.
To always changing.
Always gas.
I think he just keeps getting better
with this fight.
Gun guns blazing.
You know what I want,
but I want the fucking winner of this
light's Mighty mouse.
Mighty mouse.
Beg for it,
man.
dude.
California.
Can you imagine if your riaa faber beats
cruz anD that's a big f and then fight
mighty mouse.
Mighty mouse.
Do you hate money and fame?
Let's do a dog.
And uriah faber would,
for the first time in his career,
just dwarf somebody.
That bigger guy,
he'd be like,
sideboard on shorter is mighty mouth
quite a bit,
but at pitt he's a small guy,
but he's just lice.
He makes up for tremendous.
He's impossible to hit and possible.
That's what he's heard.
Dominick cruz in my new method before.
How is that 1:35 and dominic wanted
decision.
Yeah,
but dominic is like got his own style.
If you look at his movement and his
patterns,
good luck finding anybody to replicate
that.
His footwork and his movement and his
patterns are all designed to constantly
keep you guessing.
You're constantly like being overrun
with infoRmation of a guy stands in
front of you.
The less data that's coming your way,
the more that you have to.
You can concentrate on what's at hand
and focus on what you're trying to do.
Smartest guy in the sport I think and
dominic gives you that he doesn't give
you that.
There's never a time where he's standing
in front of you,
just tying.
You
were talking to them and you were just
blown away or training with them and he
was training me in jail.
Like we're two white pills.
Like jesus christ.
Man,
he's a wizard.
He's a wizard dude.
You're sleeping on poor.
You poor.
You know I'm not,
but I'm not sleeping.
And
Bobby Green hasn't been in a big fight
in a while too.
I'm psyched to see him back.
Bobby greens want a lot of shit talking
about.
He always does a lot of shit talking,
but Bobby Green when he's at his best,
is one of the best at 1:50.
So the diamond to man,
it feels like five now.
They fell off just a tad
and then he's at 55 and connor knocked
him out.
He got knocked out in the first round by
connor and he just,
he started.
He struggled too hard to make that
fucking wait.
Yeah.
And big dude.
Those were doing the ivy days too,
by the way.
That's right.
It's really interesting to see the
difference in a lot of these guys'
bodies now that there's so much testing.
It really is.
It's um,
some of them,
some of them for sure.
It's just like what I would always think
is if you wrestled and you did jujitsu
and you boxed and you kicked you,
you'd come out looking very,
very muscular.
When you look at guys back,
you know,
five years ago,
and you look at guys now,
there is a difference.
Like if anything they look,
they get kind of skinnier or they've
realized that here's a big one.
Epo.
If you can't use epo,
you gotta lose body mass.
You just have torres.
Yeah,
for sure.
It's a big part of endurance oxygen,
melodion law,
whatever that stuff wasn't a boxer got
caught from is it mirrors that affects
russians are balls deep and
that's what the guy who fought on you
read.
You read about the sochi olympics,
but and how they've uncovered that there
was.
They don't know how they got into those
bottles that they make in Switzerland.
They're like tamper proof,
but however they did it,
they're drawing this whole thing where
every they think 100 athletes in the
olympics were cheating on the russian,
on the russian side,
and the information came from the
russian guy who ran the lab and the
other two guys that he worked with
mysteriously died.
So this guy exiled himself to los
angeles.
He ran the entire lab and now he's
coming clean and saying,
well,
our intelligence operatives were were
basically involved in getting clean
samples to water,
et cetera.
Why is he snitching?
And it's basically out of us because
there's two colleagues work till killed
because they had.
They knew things,
so he went la and shut your mouth,
but he did know he was rushing to get
ya.
You can't shut your mouth.
He can still get them.
Yeah,
and he had to prove that he was.
He was.
His life was in danger.
Yeah.
You don't think they'd get you if you
shut your mouth and you moved to la.
OH,
you made it.
You're at home base.
You touched base.
They killed that guy in dc and the
movies they killed by russian
intelligence can find you who they kill
in dc.
This guy found he was bread with blunt
force trauma to the head.
I wonder how that happened.
Yeah,
but here's the thing,
the autopsy,
like they didn't do an autopsy for a
long time and initially the,
the cause of death was ruled as like a
heart attack and then they found a blunt
force trauma in his head.
How do you miss thAt?
Yeah,
because it's a spooky story.
X eight to putin died a blunt force
trauma at dc hotel medical examiner
says,
but like look,
when they found him and look when they.
They actually made the autopsy claim,
I think it was like quite a bit of time.
He actually died from blunt force trauma
kettlebell in the fucking head.
That's what
they did.
Some russian bugging kettle.
Then he tied him up.
They tied him up and then you just did
fucking swings right at his head.
Can you imagine somebody killed you with
a kettlebell?
Just being tied up by some russian
thugs.
Aeon,
flux brother.
Look at that.
It said family members told russian news
media and november that they thought
leslie had suffered a heart attack.
That's when they put that down in
november.
so when was this article where they
decided that this is really recently as
march?
Yeah.
See,
so there's all those months that went by
before it was announced that he was
killed in a hotel.
Now been caught just blatantly cheating
on in the olympics.
Yeah,
but this is a guy that says this.
I don't know that there's been.
I've read the article.
I don't know that there's been
definitive proof that everything he's
saying is true.
That he has an exaggerated times that
ran two articles on their front page of
the New York times is going to do that.
They've checked their sources.
Yeah,
but it's not a matter of checking
sources like what is the physical,
what's the physical evidence that you
have?
The physical,
they're there very well.
Could be a story there that the New York
times must run and I'm sure that they
checked their sources,
but is there anything that they can hold
up and say,
this needs to be examined because this
is proof positive that it'd be great if
they did see be on cnn.
They don't think it's there yet,
but look,
it's 100 percent going on.
Is anyone surprised?
No,
of course not.
We'll novitsky told me straight up that
they're figuring out a way to move
around these things and that while he's
doing this,
he's like,
I always know.
And novitsky is jeff novitsky,
who's the guy who caught lance armstrong
was guy works for the ufc now because
for people listening to.
Okay.
The golden snitch.
Yeah,
he's,
he's the guy that catches guys doing
everything and you know,
they're on top of the latest and the
greatest and he,
yeah,
and the government's money and the
latest I know he doesn't want to admit
that our money,
he wants to pretend he wants to pretend
that it was way less than that.
He was giving me like a figure on the
show and that's how,
that's why lance armstrong came on the
show because what he's not counting is
like salaries and flights and all this
stuff with their county is like the
amount of money they actually had to
spend like on voucher.
So that's.
So that's the government.
So that's the federal government with
unlimited resources.
Spending $32,
million dollars on a cyclist who still
wanted anyone.
By the way,
god still going after they're going
after him now for $100,000,000 still
because he's defrauded the government of
how much they paid him because he,
he raced for the post office,
keeps the ship.
You raise your tax dollars.
But here's the thing,
if you race for the post office,
the post office is the government.
So they charge you for three times what
you took.
So if you took 33,
they're charging them for a million
calls.
It tyranny.
Riding a bike.
Yeah.
Thirty three.
They go after him for 100 letters,
write a letter to the government,
see what happens.
He's the ultimate golden snitch.
Why you say golden snitch was the golden
because he's at another level just.
But he's not a snItch.
He's an investigator.
He's not to involve a snitch.
Will be victor conte.
Victor conte is a snitch.
He got to content on top.
But he didn't even rat on people.
When he got caught you.
He can't even call him a snitch.
You call them a post operative because
he lived on rats where I come from,
but he's.
See,
here's the thing.
He used to be involved in it.
He's not involved in anymore.
Now he's going after people who are
involved with it.
So what is that?
That's like an informer.
But can I ask you a question?
Did they ever actually.
Jamie says,
yes.
Joe did to kind of be a snitch because
he's really revealing all this
backstory,
but he could be reforMed and since
you're primarily concentrates on combat
sports athletes,
you could see him as a.
He's helping people like he'S keeping
people from cheating content or content.
Could you see it that way?
Sure,
but he benefited.
The reason why he has a name reasonably
get so big is because he was helping so
many big name athletes and then now he's
against it,
but should that can be affected?
Who's helping all those big name
athletes could,
should that disclude him from being able
to realize the error of his ways and
make an attempt to try to clean up the
sport?
Is that possible?
It's possible.
Right and possible.
That's how I hope to look at it.
If they ever find physical evidence,
physical evidence test that that showed
that lance armstrong actually cheated,
has never commented,
so 500 tests or whatever it was,
whatever it was,
he never.
He passed all of them.
Thirty $2,
million dollars later,
but finally he admits that he used
performance enhancing drugs to oprah.
Yeah,
but it's very interesting to me.
What do you think the beneFit of that
was,
and I do think that there's a benefit to
going after people who are cheating,
who are trying to change the playing
field.
I know everybody does.
I know everybody does,
but it's an.
It's a.
It's a difficult thing because.
Well,
first of all,
it's not an american game.
You're in another country,
so you're,
you're giving someone some sort of a.
You're,
you're investigating them being involved
in something that's not even taking
place on american soil.
So that's the dubious right there.
Second of all you are saying as the post
office,
you're suing this guy for all the money
that he made while he was cheating and
using drugs.
If you don't know that cyclists are
cheating,
what the fuck are you doing in the
cyclist business?
Because I know I'm a comedian living in
la and I know they're all cheating
exact,
so I know how much did he do for the us
postal office and also a lot of cycling.
Cycling to lance I'm sure started
kicking ass.
Correct.
And how much money did you raise for all
this cancer?
We have a lot.
How Many people were running those
yellow wristband?
But,
but that doesn't disclose the,
here's the issue.
This is where he fucked up.
He Sued a bunch of people that were
telling the truth and he uses money.
That's where he fucked up.
That's,
that's where he's a bad guy at that
point.
But also in his spoil,
you have to go down to 15th place.
They were all doing it.
The level playing field.
Right?
So it was about everybody was ratting on
everybody.
They were,
they got caught.
They were giving people up,
there was a lot of that going on.
And lance armstrong starts suing people
when they given up him.
That is where people have an issue with
it.
And when his mind was touching himself,
right.
And um,
I can see both sides,
but I'm with lance armstrong,
like,
dude,
you're a snitch on me.
I gotta protect myself too.
Exactly.
I started at first snitching on me and
the stitching.
If,
if we're boys,
the snitching is worse than the lawsuit
by far.
Especially was a team.
Yes,
we represent America,
but some of those guys weren't his boys
anymore.
They didn't like them anymore.
So why snitch?
Very few people like.
Did you get anything out of it?
You.
I'm with you
the word,
but a lot of people,
a lot of people didn't like and lance
armstrong,
they disliked the same reason why they
don't like fucking Michael Jordan.
Let me tell you something about
armstrong was on the podcast.
He wanted her to know what number the
podcast had gotten up to.
What's it up to his up number one yet
because it was like number two in the
country.
Tell me what hits number one.
I'm going to hit number one in the
country.
I to let them know how many downloads
getting he wants.
He wants to know has it gotten more than
other people's downloads?
Like he's.
He goes,
I'm real quick,
easy,
open about.
He laughs about it.
He's like,
I'm fucking competitive.
Like you know me,
I'm competitive.
Like he's,
he wants to.
He wanted to have the number one podcast
of all time.
I don't think that way.
Fuck,
I wish that's why you're not lance
armstrong bitch sway.
Just wrestled in high school though.
Jitsu with henzel gracie.
I got my pay.
You got your.
what?
I thought you said.
Yeah.
You know I never said that.
Wait a minute.
Never to see.
We have to go back to the audience.
I didn't want to touch on.
I never said that holder in my life.
did he say he has?
No,
I've never said that.
I'm so confused.
I don't know.
What do you mean you don't know?
I don't lie.
Wait a minute.
There's lies and then there are lies
that anybody has said.
They're a purple belt is a liar.
I'm a liar,
but I'm not a liar.
You know what I mean?
You definitely didn't say you're a
purple belt.
Oh,
I never said it was a purple
accidentally.
Once.
A little bit drunk.
I never even said it.
Tapped a purple truck.
ProbablY did once.
Saying b is the reason why he's lance
armstrong,
because these can be competitive at
everything.
Anyone who's an ultra winter you just
said,
I wish I was like that.
I'm not.
why would you wish you would like you
are going to be a cyclist?
No,
dude.
What you want to be,
what you are is a guy who always wants
to be something other than you.
ExActly,
and that's paRt of the fun being around.
Brian.
I wish it was that guy and then you'd go
into this romanticized version with that
guy is as well.
That guy lives liviNg in austin and
people throw an exit his house.
Yeah.
CAn't post sociAl media and I hate.
It's sort of relaxing a bit now,
but I mean look to when,
when the storm comes your way,
like when you get in trouble for
something along those lines,
the storm of being a national disgrace
and you know,
and someone who everyone's selling green
and there's so much going on with the
lawsuits and the and he's still involved
in a lawsuit with the post office.
Like the storm of pressure and stress is
probably overwhelming and never end,
but also gives everyone now have voice
on social media who's never done shit in
their lives to fucking contribute and
try and shit on lance armstrong where
the greatest athletes of all time,
oh fuck,
damn,
fuck with this guy.
And then you post thIs a picture of your
kids at christmas.
Oh fuck these kids.
Where's their steroid?
That man me feel better about yourself.
He's still killing it.
He's still living in a mansion.
Yeah,
I mean it's just part of the program.
So it comes to the program and I don't
think he's a bad guy.
It was amazing talking tO them.
A great podcast.
I listened to it.
He's my buddy now.
We text each other bazaars,
floss,
and I get a text every now and then from
lance armstrong.
When dan bilzerian,
when dan bilzerian was doing that bet.
He's doing a bet where he rode a bike to
las vegas.
I didn't see it.
Yeah.
Well he.
I don't know if he's talked about it
publicly.
I don't know if he's talked about the
fact that he did it.
Anyway.
He,
uh,
lance armstrong texted me and he's like,
you know,
dan bilzerian hook us up.
I want to help them.
Some fuckIng.
Lance armstrong helped dan bilzerian
trained for this thing where he's got a
ride to vegas and 30 hours it like,
you could totally do it.
It's totally doable.
Aaron make his money.
That's a good question.
I don't know.
I think his parents had money because he
was going,
what I know from the internet is there
saying,
I love what you do that with air quotes,
internet
underworld.
He was playing that he has all this
money,
all this stuff from being one of these
top poker players in the world.
But It came out that he comes from a lot
of money on this lifestyle,
like,
you know,
lIke shooting guns with this color and
blah blah was drafting against the
rules.
He wasn't allowed to draft.
That's what I did most of the trip I
think is behind a van like that.
Oh,
where someone drove the van.
Well,
his beard is a major air drag.
Yeah.
Well,
that's a big deal.
I don't know if it wasn't within the
rules.
Maybe you should have set the rules
before they made that,
especially if the wind is headed his
face.
If the wind that y'all got hustled,
the whim is headed towards his face,
but you know what,
if they didn't put that in the rules,
they fucked up because bilzerian is a
smart bitch and look what he's got to.
The vans back.
Doors are open so they could have a fan
blowing on him.
But like mr and shit,
he's a pimp.
How do you not love that guy?
Every picture he takes got 100 whores
with him.
It does say I say that with all love,
all love and respect.
Humans private jets and say he has 100
beautiful women with them because that's
what he does,
but that's kind of his persona.
Charlie's angels.
It's a lot of work.
I don't know.
Yeah,
actually it is worth kind of like
dilating out a little bit.
Like,
I don't know,
it's just not thAt inspiring to me and
I
can tell you right up,
you can tell you right now what brian's
trying to do is say that he's not a fan
of this guy.
He's trying to be very pc because you
never fucking draw the line with
anybody.
I just don't like this culture that is
essentially celebrating itself.
I just don't.
That's not a guy to hang out with.
When you're that happy with yourself and
you think,
hey,
you know,
I was going to spend met him.
Guy,
my business manager saying spending 125
k on a private jet was a bad idea.
I disagree with this naked girl.
Alright,
I'm sure I'd love hanging out with them,
but it's just not that inspiring to me,
but you have to realize that people
doing this or akin in a lot of ways too.
Gangsta rappers like what they're doing
is putting out an image.
That image becomes popular.
That popular image equates to millions
and millions of followers on instagram
because he's manipulated the media.
Yes to all and he can,
but he can use that to promote himself
and all sorts of different ways and then
he becomes a business mode himself.
Exactly.
That's what you do when you're promoting
shows,
but I'm saying is like a person promotes
himself on instagram.
What's a girl's got yoga pants and a
nice big,
but she makes money all of a sudden
doing squats and I'm at it.
I mean there's a lot of those people,
but there's a difference.
Yeah,
look at that time.
What's the difference between a girl
sticking her butt out or him?
He's got $17.
Million is two.
There's no difference.
You're just saying it's not inspiring.
Yeah.
I'm saying like,
don't you think it's a little bit maybe
like the difference between you see a
body that's built for something like if
you look at joe showings body,
it's built for a purpose and then you
see somebody who's a bodybuilder all due
respect to body parts is a hard thing to
do.
Look on there,
but it's just that cool.
I don't know.
Three is 343,000.
You're saying he doesn't have.
He doesn't have skills,
you're saying he doesn't possess the
skill,
skill of self promotion,
but it ends there.
so thing.
But you say that,
but how do you know?
Because he's also a professional poker
player,
makes millions of dollars gambling.
So they say so is it debatable?
Yes.
Well,
didn't he win this fucking debate that
he won this million dollar bet to go to
vegas?
But he did it.
I meAn he worked hard.
He worked hard for five weeks to do
that.
It's not like an empty guy with no
character.
It might be.
I don't know what might be some
stiffness.
He might be a wild,
fun seeking motherfucker that's actually
pulling it off as a marketing genius.
If you were a guy I didn't have any set
of skills and all of a sudden by hook or
by crook or by luck or by fuck you find
yourself with $100,000,000.
Wouldn't you want to live like this?
You got a mansion that top of the hill
and you don't know.
I wouldn't.
I try to make a difference.
Brian hang out with people that are way
more shallow.
I don't know.
I don't.
I do not,
sir.
Hold on.
Stop for a second and Just consider
this.
I want to attack you.
Did we not talk about someone before
this show that you used to hang out
with?
All the time.
That is equally as fucked up as that
guy.
I'm tRying to think of who.
Whatever.
Do you mean right before the show as too
complicated.
Listen,
no,
the answers.
I don't want to.
I don't know the guy I've met him.
He seems nice.
I know,
I know.
I'm just saying brian likes that guy
because he has skills to be.
If you can be $100,000,000,
listen,
you can be 100 million dollars.
You know what I'm going to do the
responsibility.
Don't say I'm reading your mind to make
a difference in the world and you try
and do that.
Now.
I am at least,
at least with the skills I have.
What are you doing?
Well,
I'm trying to be as original as I can,
but you're not doing that because you
enjoy it because you're entertaining
people.
Okay.
You're not.
You're not going out seeking to make a
difference in the world.
You're going out having a good time,
making it,
doing a good packed.
That's exactly right,
but I also do try to make a difference
in the world in my own way charity wise
and things like that.
I do.
I spend money on charity.
I spend money to make the world.
If you give me a $100,000,000,
had a guy,
but let's be honest,
you're not a guy who's like really
promoting charities a lot and talking
about it a lot and giving money to go to
do is.
What I'm trying to do is go to friends
here.
Let's just take,
let's take standup.
So stand up for me with stand up.
At least what I'm trying to do in my own
mind is surprised myself and come up
with,
you know,
see what I'm made of and trying to get
people doing your thing.
That's your way of giving.
This is not a criticism of your standup.
I think you're hilarious.
No,
I love.
Yeah.
I think you're saying is that what I'm
saying is that I think there's a
difference between the skill of standup,
for example,
and come up with a body of work and
taken all that money and shooting guns
and being on a private jet and having
chicks.
Here's the problem.
We know he's not giving to charity
though.
listen man,
you don't know that and here's the deal.
He might.
He might be.
I don't know.
It might not be.
Who knows,
but what I'm seeing is a show.
It's a very short snippet show.
What you just saw there when he's
walking by that girl's butt and he's got
a machine.
Look,
not only you,
but here's the thing.
Obviously this is staged.
This is a fucking show is a chemistry.
THe way it was shot.
There's a camera behind him.
He's moving in slow mo.
He's got a bandolier on dude.
Do you not see how ridiculous it is?
I do stand up like that.
Brian.
Listen,
let's just open minded.
You're watching the video.
He's in a dune buggy with all these hot
chicks.
Do you think this is really happening?
That they just get candice,
candice huffine just on on noticed video
of him driving around this dune buggy
with all these hot chicks.
He hired someone just walking in slow
motion with his bandolier.
The girls are laughing.
Is are all rent is a goddamn show.
I'll be with you.
All I'm saying is even if you got
$100,000,000,
you're not becoming a mother.
Theresa known here is.
no,
I'm not,
but I'm just saying don't pretend that
that's the only issue I have not.
I'm just not.
All I said was I don't find it that
inspiring.
It says it is.
Yeah.
We're not inspired.
We're not saying jesus christ.
Dan bilzerian makes me want to go give
money to charity.
No,
I'm just saying why?
Why even be upset that I'm upset.
I'm saying that sucking your teeth and
crossing your legs.
Being dramatic,
but I think cei or by him.
I was based at the circle.
I know that's what we're calling you out
on,
but hold on,
hold on.
You have to.
There is criteria for how to live your
life.
There's criteria,
how to live your life,
and I think if you spent $125,
million thousand dollars,
I'm whatever on looking great and
celebrating yourself.
I just think it kind of.
it's just not really.
Yeah,
it's.
It's a brilliant marketing plan.
I get that.
It might not be your thing.
It doesn't have to be your thing.
It's exactly what I'd do with my.
My point is like,
to me it's not offensive at all.
No more offensive than the kardashians.
The kardashians don't offend me.
I mean,
I can make fun of it all day long,
but I'm not offended by what they're
doing.
I don't think anything's wrong with it.
I do itself celebration and I find that
very.
I just all around.
It's not my favorite thing,
but it doesn't bother me saying,
I think this guy is funny.
I think this,
this instagram,
what I'm taken out of this to me is
amusement and humor.
This is what I'm getting.
I see it as a persona,
like it's a gimmick.
Look at that picture on the couch.
Like to me,
this is an exaggeration of all the
stereotypes of some super rich guy that
doesn't exist.
Hey,
he's got the girl me hanging around in
their underwear.
They're all in lingerie,
but if this,
this is leftover random picture,
would that be.
Listen,
it is.
I mean,
just think about it.
It is.
His life probably gets old after a
while.
It's taking these photos with this
girls,
these girls,
and I'm sure some of them have sex with
them.
Yeah.
I hope 100 perCent.
Otherwise he's got real legitimately has
unbelievable amounts of money.
Like he's got a house in the hollywood
hills.
How weird is that?
These girls are around.
Is it weird?
It's weird.
These girls around.
Just because you have money,
but you know it.
Who cares?
I wouldn't care if I was handling it.
Well,
here's the thing.
He's not a bad looking bad looking manly
dude in front of your gq.
Yeah,
he's not bad.
I mean,
here's the thing,
remember we were talking about the salt.
No bernai.
Yeah.
Who hires these girls and he pays them
like a thousands of dollars a day to
hang out at his house and he fucks them
occAsionally.
He decides who he wants to fuck.
He has a whole disco built into one of
his palaces,
the prince,
and he comes down.
He knew sachets through the fucking
room.
Naked does whatever the fuck.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
He just picks the girls who wants to
bang and then brings them up to his
room.
But all of them are getting ungodly
amounts of money and jewelry,
diamonds and all this shit.
So we look at that guy.
We don't have a problem with it.
Well,
I don't.
I never said I didn't have a problem.
Do you have a problem with it?
I just haven't.
Don't that
bitches and gold royals royce.
He has like 100 ferrari's.
Bam.
Pitch.
Killing the game.
Yeah,
but kill him.
Kill what gay is.
Expression.
Killing the golden jeannie game.
Killing the real goals now for me and
excess.
So profanity.
Oh brian.
But yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
But that's the.
You're.
You're like,
you're doing duh.
Like duh.
Duds,
gluttony.
But it's hilarious.
Come up and do doing some shit for his
people though to hey,
hey,
hey.
Might be.
We don't take it easy.
We don't know.
That's the thing.
That's his fleet of cars.
That's one of them.
That's his value system.
It's okay.
Oh,
right.
That's
my problem with you is you're acting
like your mother teresa.
I'm not doing all this shit.
I'm not coming down to the fact is that
we,
we do live in a culture that somehow
celebrates that and I just find it kind
of boring.
It is.
But for example,
you don't have to,
but you don't have to celebrate it to
it.
Like,
look,
it is what it is.
It's part of the folly of humanity.
Yes.
I think it's,
I think it's a music or taking a sense
of humor and you should be,
you should take a humorous approach to
it.
And um,
I bet you that guy dan bilzerian is
probably actually a funny guy and a
silly goose.
I would imagine.
When I met him he was very nice.
He doesn't assume that,
well,
I don't give a shit what I was using him
as an expression.
It's an expression of kind of what this
culture has to offer.
Whenever you make a point and I see
you're wearing boots and these are like
a taser to zip up boots too,
and I see that and you need cross your
legs and has a really elegant way that I
can't even do.
You can't do that.
I know that you can't cross flexible
enough that dick,
you got fat,
but I also have fat.
Let it happen.
I tell leg,
I take my skinny jeans on it happening.
I tape my genitals down to my mother.
By the way,
I see you're wearing the fucking
stretchy jeans.
They're wearing them.
When you were doing during the kid,
it's all or were you wearing them now?
These are my five for jeans.
I wear
jeans are my five fours.
Five fourths.
These are stretchy jeans.
That's what I will call it a stretch to.
So why do you guys need stretchy jeans
is so good because that's a huge legs.
I you fucking john.
Oh no,
no,
no.
I'm telling you,
these jeans,
I'm wearing sweat pants,
bro.
We both have blow out.
We have blow out assets and some people
now that cell,
they call,
they call them like the brand of
stretchy.
They're calling them like rogan jeans
and not that I know there's already a
company called rogan genes,
right?
There's already a company called rogan
genes and somebody made,
but this is like a type,
like some people are selling stretchy
ones as being stretched.
As I talk about.
Here's a strategy too.
I swear to god.
What are you talking about?
All I wear now,
so what are you talking about?
I every company has some of stretchy
jeans.
If you go to the story,
if these are skinny jeans,
stretchy jeans,
they've got spandex and I mean it's all
I wear now.
Our chains are awesome dude.
Regular canvas jeans like keto
saccharine,
tick.
It's so scratchy and itchy and want
something that's going to hug my fucking
legs off that room.
I used to have to wear lucky brand
jeans.
Like there's a certain [inaudible] lucky
brand jeans is a thicker cut.
There's like a few different companies
that will make our thicker cut,
that'll fit my troll.
Like you've got a small waist,
but big thighs.
Yeah,
and it's my upper thighs or the highest
where it's way thicker from.
It's all kicking stuff when you do it
like it has a child like developed in
that way.
One of the highlights of my life,
and I'm a skinny guy,
the highlights of my life was when I was
at john varvatos trying on impossibly
expensive jeans and and couldn't fit.
My calves are my upper thighs.
They were just too tight.
He was so happy.
I looked at the guy albums.
I got huge caps.
I got cast.
I got the biggest kick.
Well,
they're big for your rest of your body.
He said the biggest bodybuilder I'd be,
dude,
I got.
Those calves are ridiculous.
They don't even look.
Hearts hearts.
He's got this maga,
moose heart that would be a bit of
mousse out of the fridge.
Straight up and it looks just like his
cat.
Yeah,
he's got a couple moves.
Hearts stuffed into his legs,
but he's a gorilla of a dude.
When like he's one of those guys like,
boy,
I'm glad he's jolly because if he just
started just running through a room for
the people even including me to pull me
over,
I pushed him into a room with a bunch of
people who are recognized him and I
pushed him into this room and I went,
I'm will sasso,
and everybody looked up and went,
turned he turned.
I tried to hold the door and he pushed
the door and sent me into the street.
He's a five,
3:30.
Oh,
he's the funniest guy.
Will sasso.
You should have them on this podcast.
He's to me,
him and zach alphadex.
Funniest people in the world.
Just off the top of your podcast
recently and bum you out does.
It wasn't like he was bombed because he
was bummed when I was sick,
but the first thing he said is he goes,
if you're almost burst,
and I don't know why these guys just
don't grab a seat.
I'll kick it in the ocean,
break its wing and fucking eat right
there are going to get weird.
He's fucking.
He came on.
He was just sick.
He's like on a bunch of antibiotics.
Will is fucking hilarious.
Will is jaw droppingly funny.
What did we hang out with them less?
Was it in vancouver?
We after ufc.
He's canadian.
The comedy store,
wasn't it?
Or an or?
No,
we went to dinner with him at a
restaurant in Canada somewhere in
toronto.
Maybe it was.
What do we do with a vancouver?
Canada?
Wasn't toronto.
So much fun going on.
Steve over there.
The little bottle brother.
Dude,
I still am thinking about the show.
I did.
Joe let me do 50 minutes at the chicago
theater in front of 3,500 people.
50.
That was pretty cool,
man.
That's pretty cool.
That's pretty awesome game.
So we had a good time.
It's funny how a giant crowd like that
though in some ways is so different than
like an intimate crowd.
Works like timing's yeah.
Yeah.
The laughter kind of roles and you got
to wait.
Whereas I'm here.
You're not aware of your effect with a
huge crowd like that.
In the same way as you're aware of your
effect with 200 people,
you have you ever sat,
you know,
what's a really good thing to do is sit
in the audience when someone's on stage
like that,
if you ever get a chance,
like if you want to see Louis Black.
I was working the night after he was at
a theater in New Jersey and me and diaz
went across the street to the theater
and uh,
you know,
we sat down in the audience.
We actually got like seats in a nice
spot,
but it was a nice spot like in the
middle towards the back and I was amazed
at how difficult it is to understand
really what he's saying once the
laughter roles because when you're on
stage,
when you're on stage,
you're,
you hear your mic,
you have monitors that are projecting
towards you and you're saying things and
the punchline hits and then the people
laugh.
You have to be real careful what you're
saying.
Wow.
People are laughing.
Don't miss it because it's different
than a comedy club in a comedy club.
You can just hammer over it.
Yes.
There's 200 people in there.
You say something that's funny,
they're laughing and you could add a tag
in the middle of it and it makes even
funny ideas.
Joey diaz as the master of that.
He just like in the middle of people
laughing,
it'll slam you with something else and
then slammed me with something else.
But in a theater that's like 3000 plus
people.
You have to wait because when I was
sitting in the audience it,
it occurred to me like,
oh,
when people are laughing around you,
it's like people yelling at you because
you right there in the speakers way the
fuck over there.
So we like wait a minute.
Guest who's doing guest who's doing
really well with his 10 minutes,
we do our live show.
I make them get up there.
I'm like,
you're going to do stand up,
dude.
900 people.
Chicago had him dion for 10 minutes.
I was.
I looked at his brother.
Your brother's doing stand up.
He's done this maybe 10 times and he
fucking killing it and adding shit in
the middle of the act.
Like adding should.
I hadn't seen like he's playing with the
crowds and reacting and then adding
something else.
I was like,
this is fucking beautiful man and doing
this like this without a crowd.
Completely different.
But you're always funny doing this.
Just remember what you said and repeat
it.
That's all I do.
I tell a story,
like,
have different stories.
I'm just telling stories and add stuff
to it.
But going back to your point about the
theater,
you know,
I'm brand new at this so I thought
everything was the same and brian and I
went to do the shows like 700 people
sold out,
but it was a giant ballroom and brian's
like,
now don't get discouraged because you're
not gonna be able to hear it as well.
So I'd like,
you know,
do some of my bits.
I,
I could kind of hear him laughing,
but it's kind of,
you're not getting that.
And I'm like,
what the fuck is wrong with these
people?
We got to the back.
I was like,
fuck them bro.
He's like,
no man,
I told you so because I go based off the
crowd's reaction.
We'll get off stage.
You're like,
dude,
that was a sick show or do that sucked
and he's like,
no,
I'm telling you,
you're not gonna be able to gauge it off
this because we've been in small comedy
place where I'm like,
holy shit,
I'm like fucking joe rogan.
Amazing.
And then there's other ones where I'm
like,
what the fuck is going on with these
people?
He's like,
it's the venue we're leaving.
Carbs is kind of interesting because
cops is like 400 something and the
ceilings rather high because it has a
balcony.
So like the old,
the old cops was crazy fun.
The old cops is like,
I want to say like 150 people max.
It was probably less than that.
It was really small and it was tight and
I used to do it.
A lot of people like dom rarely used to
do it and take a loss.
He could get more money other places,
but he would do carbs just because it
was so enjoyable.
That's cool man.
Everywhere we go.
You don't have all the famous people in
the walls.
I was take pictures.
I'll show you.
Picture like sydney picture,
like look who's here?
Yeah,
bitch.
Big time comedian.
You know,
it's like,
yeah,
quit send me pictures.
I'm always like looking at my boy.
Like you're new to the game.
I'm thinking like selfies with you.
Like what the fuck you dude.
You been thrown into me.
I think it's funny.
It doesn't.
I'm not.
I'm not going.
Yeah,
I know where you're going to pitch.
And then our.
And then we had a manager go to wilbur.
Man,
this is this much going as you know,
just let you know where you guys that.
So rogan sold out four times and I was
like,
why the fuck you?
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
And chris rock solid at madison square
garden,
which is fucking trying to hurt my
feelings.
It's joe for this guy who deals with.
We deal with at the wilbur.
Like it's the fucking.
It's a giant theater man.
I'm very aware of what brogan read.
Why are you even bringing that up?
Mike and lebron james dunks a basketball
booming when you're talking about this a
bit.
I've done stand up 34 times.
That's it.
Yeah.
I wished 35 only at live shows.
How many live shows have you guys done
together?
Probably have 10,
10,
15,
11.
I guess it's going to be doing stand up
at the wilbur this friday in boston.
That guy right there go on up.
It's going to be,
I don't know.
We're selling a lot of tickets to
wilbur's one of the best theaters to do
standup in because it's a three tier and
they're really shallow.
Meaning the people right on top of you.
Huh?
So even though there's more than a
thousand people in the room,
it feels way more intimate.
It seems like a bunch of 300 seaters
stacked on top of each other.
It seems like the same.
I can't wait.
You can get some valuable have to k dot,
dot,
dot dot.
You get a feeling like,
like a 300 seat theater,
but a roar of a thousand people.
I can't wait because they were in New
York too and doing,
you know,
are bitten a New York.
Be crazy man.
Well,
um,
I took tony hinchcliffe with me to a,
to a boston and now he's going to go
back and headline that place.
He's going to do,
uh,
the one night at the wilbur and october.
There it is right there.
See outside that place is sick.
Yeah,
it's beautiful.
And it's been around the wilbur wright,
right.
Fights it too,
but that's a bird's eye view.
Uh,
you know,
it's a distorted view of the levels.
Camera lens,
that's going to be my favorite supplier
has been the vic in chicago,
the big theater.
That's what's called,
right the vic.
I love the vick,
bUt I think that was a fact.
Right?
That sounds terrific.
Chicago was nice,
Like an older theater too,
on soMe big ass place in chicago in july
I'm doing fight where,
where's the chicago bulls play cell net,
but on the civic opera house and doing
The opera sing,
just start it off.
Like
maybe I should have someone,
I'd hire someone to sing some opera
opera.
So who's the blInd guy?
But jim jefferies does opera.
He used to be an opera singer.
Yes.
The last guy thought that photo up.
That's a really good photo.
That sick.
Which women when we.
This is the civic opera house.
Dude,
you're doing that.
You're going to fill it up.
It's all gold.
Look at that prince's room.
That's really awesome.
That's dope.
That's the principle.
Nih
horse.
That's exactly the same.
That's the same design on his underwear
on his me undies.
Come on.
You know that dude has gold underwear.
Why wouldn't you?
You ran out of ideas.
I'm saying right now.
I want some.
Anyone has 24 karat gold underwear.
Sandlot I've camel underwear.
Come on.
Don't be like me too.
Usually hide them.
Pp stains,
motherfucker.
Yeah.
There you go.
I got those are me and that's your sweet
and asked me to do the best anywhere in
the world.
Even if these fucking dropped me as a
sponsor,
I'll tell you where those goddamn
underwear.
they're fucking shit.
I can't have him on the outside and
white on the inside though.
Cameras that will you have.
I wear the shit on my face that were
trying to spy for.
They want yoU to see what damage you're
doing to your underwear,
man.
Hey man,
let's go.
Cam on camera and make a jungle camera
at that.
We do.
We do reads For me undies and he's like,
man,
he's no more life but underwear plaCe
ted talk on the workplace.
Some cool light ones too though with
some interesting cool prints on them.
All artsy and shit.
They're dope.
What I love about that company and all
these companies that are emerging on the
internet don't have like an actual
store.
There's just selling things online.
Like they figured out like you don't
need a place who wants to go somewhere?
How easy is it to just order something,
have It sent to you and then you like.
How much of a difference is like getting
things in the mail these days as opposed
to go into stores?
Like how much of an impact has that had
an actual retail store really?
is there anything in a package like this
five,
four club.com,
whatever thing.
We literally.
It's like 60 bucks for like legit,
like everything I'm wearing.
Have you done club?
Great wine way cheaper.
13 bucks for,
for really good wine.
So you're right man,
they cut it.
They cut out the uh,
how everything we do every year,
every one of our sponsors,
I actually use the products because
they're good to me too.
I love that.
I haven't made a website yet with
squarespace,
but I want to.
But the other things like dollar shave
club,
I don't buy razors anymore.
Do you ever used that?
That butter shit,
that versus butter.
Oh my god.
It's so nice.
We're going to have.
We're trying to get the guy who started
that company on because he's really
funny.
Who does all the commercials?
Oh,
it doesn't,
that's him.
THe guy who started an improv guy
started with some company.
They don't want to go.
Yeah.
We gotta get them out of pocket.
He's funny.
Well,
I just love this time.
It's funny because it's really the same
thing.
That's what's going on with podcasts.
You guys don't need like any sort of
account.
You guys kind of have a company though.
You kind of have fox.
I mean,
not really.
We have.
Because again,
they don't tell you what to do but can't
tried.
Not where they started.
They've been,
but they can't do it.
Actually been so good.
They put this whole.
they know,
they know.
If they're like,
hey,
don't do that.
I'm like,
what do I do?
That's the thing is like you guys have
an advantageous position in the
relationship.
It's not like a regular show where they
could fire you from it.
Yeah.
If they fire you,
you will have zero impact,
but also it actually helped us because
just tell everyone what went down and I
will tell all the fox dirt and I will
blast picture almost
fucking.
I've always been a snitch.
I'm that golden snitch.
Truth comes out
soon before someone fucking makes a
photoshop of you in the salt obadiah's
outfit.
I jusT says golden snitch,
golden snitch.
That photoshop seed guy is going to be
talking about what's happened with that
guy and snitch sweating right now and
fucking put it all together.
Just the golden snitch
fucking salt newburg,
ny picture was the perfect picture for
you.
Just put your head on his little body.
That little boy.
Oh my god.
It's called.
He has a little snitch and they do it.
It's like the same picture that they use
for the golden child.
Use the cover,
the same font and everything.
The eddie murphy movie.
So funny man.
Yeah,
me too.
Arsenio haLl back in the day.
It was a good movie back in the day.
That was when eddie murphy was in its
heyday.
Try bringing city hall back.
Your st joe.
He goes,
wHo?
Who?
Two thousand 16 bitch.
Get the fuck outta here.
That didn't work well.
It was also the real problem with that
not working.
There was a bunch of different problems.
They try to do the same show.
Same.
He's even dressed the same,
doing the same bit.
He looks the same.
It looks the same.
Haircut some standup.
He's a real nice guy.
I can't say a bad word about that guy
ever.
Arsenio hall is a real nice guy.
Why?
WHy isn't eddie murphy do stand anymore?
I thought he was going to start trying
to.
You know one man,
eddie murphy has that trainee stuff that
the transgender prostitutes stuff
hanging over his head.
I'm sure.
So he's a friend.
Michael will be funny dude.
When I was with charlie,
people called charlIe out on it.
There were yelling out to charlie.
Have you seen that?
He's girl.
Yeah,
I'm sure.
Look,
I look.
Talk about the golden.
He's got them any murphy,
but here's the thing.
He did an awards show recently and he
like went up and talked about cosby and
did material about cosby and it was
fucking great.
It wasn't just great is his timing was
amazing.
It was great.
We see it.
Is it?
Yeah,
it's online.
See jamie.
Jamie will try to find.
I got to see this.
It's so good that it makes you go,
whoa.
If this guy was doing standup,
he would be fucking murder.
I think he just dOesn't care anymore.
Just like richie's absolutely so rich
and absolutely so busy and he likes
doing movies and when he does movies
he's in a lot of ways.
He's like sheltered from all these
people that would fuck with them.
He hasn't done in a movie in awhile
though.
I'm for sure make nutty professor for.
I don't know what he's done in a while.
I haven't really been paying attention,
but I mean the amount of money that
eddie murphy's made from all those
movies as the donkey,
he made him a billion dollars.
It's like,
you know,
he looks like assault and I mean there's
animators and there's a lot of other
people could've done that too.
It's not like it was impossible to do
without eddie murphy,
but what he has accomplished,
I mean financially it's probably
staggering.
Same.
So beverly hills cop,
I could see him not wanting to grind to
go out when you live like the sultan of
Brunei to bring it back full circle.
Wonderful to those candles area.
But tell you what though.
I met him in a way.
He was nice.
Fuck eddie.
Really cool.
Yeah,
it was real friendly.
Real nice.
Yeah,
there it is.
Hold on a second.
Go from the beginning.
Him.
He's aged.
Great.
Yeah.
Was who has black people on age really
do that?
Well,
he's in his fifties.
What happened?
What'd you do?
What's that?
Bill has when you say back?
No,
because I know it was a big outcry from
people.
It was trying to get bill to give his
trophies back
when they want you to give your
trophies.
He's should do one show.
We just come out and just talk crazy.
I would like to talk
who
that should give back.
My.
Yes,
so he's so good at.
That was edited in sensors a little bit.
Yeah.
Obviously I'm looking at all this.
Dave chappelle.
This is just a story piece.
Murphy makes cosby jokes at award
ceremonies.
They didn't want to do the whole thing
anyway.
You guys can find it.
I'm sure it was the name of the award
from the mark twain award from earlier
this year.
I'm telling you,
man,
I just looking at that thing right there
when you're talking about.
The guy hasn't done standup in forever
and he just goes up there and murders it
like that and is imperfect form.
His timing is perfect.
He's a fucking fantastic standup,
huh?
Amazing.
Unbelievable.
Taisha pell would act crazy.
Run to again.
Now I see him all the time.
I see on your instagram.
Yeah.
We hang out at the comedy store all the
time.
He's your boy.
He's always there.
He took me some eyes wide shut party in
the middle of the hollywood hills,
but you had a.
You had to get in an elevator and go to
the top of this hill.
Yeah,
it was.
Naomi campbell had his birthday party
and so dave's like,
hey joe,
you want to go with me to this party?
And I'm like,
dude,
I don't.
I don't like going to those parties.
I liked avoiding celebrity things.
Like,
oh,
come on man,
I got to be back here by midnight
anyway.
And I go,
all right,
so we're looking crazy amounts of weed.
Fuck we,
we get my porsche will
go up to the top of this hill,
get even more baked.
Go get,
get in a shuttle that takes you up to
this dude's house.
And some dude who has the sickest house
at the top of the hollywood hill.
It's just some crazy billionaire
character who has a sick house and then
above is sick house.
He has a sick party house type.
He has just a party house.
So you go to the top of this house and
he has this fucking insane view.
The city where it looks like blade
runner,
you know,
and he's got 180 degrees of windows is
party house is like a,
like a flying saucer that just got stuck
in the side of a building,
but the whole outside edge of the flying
saucer is all windows.
So you're sitting there,
there's all seats around the windows and
then he has this big bar and as I mean
the guy's just closes all loaded and we
have to take an elevator,
like a foreperson elevator openair
elevator that goes up the side of the
hill and as we're going up the side of
the hill and naomi campbell's naked
photo is 40,
50 feet tall and I'm not kidding,
I'm not exaggerating,
it's just enormous naked photo of naomi
campbell and then we'd get up to the top
and it's like fucking to me more is
there and I'm saying hi To lenny
kravitz.
I'm like,
this is so strange.
So high plus barbecue
barbecued,
so,
so high.
Shouldn't be out in public and up there
with all these fucking super rich.
I'm like,
What's up lenny?
Hey,
what's up man?
How you doing?
We're talking to lenny kravitz,
like how bizarre is this just seems.
Yeah,
it seems really nice,
but it was all these.
I was talking on these musician dudes
about mma.
It was like I got cornered by all these
musicians.
Started throwing up fighting.
Oh my god,
man.
Dude.
People get so excited.
He gets so excited.
They want to start talking.
mma.
Got a guy who knows have.
Meanwhile I'm like anything to relax my
anxiety.
Right?
I'll tell you all the shit I had.
Break down,
whatever you want to know.
Who's gonna win.
He was with the weirdest part about it.
Like there was one point in the night,
noemi campbell was for a book that she
has has a book coming out and she's very
nice too,
by the way.
Super nice and beautiful timepiece.
One hundred percent.
I don't know how old she is.
She's got to be 40,
I hope.
I would imagine.
Closer to fIfty really?
Because it on the backside.
Crawford is 50 now.
I think she's 49.
I think she's a little older than that.
I think she's.
She's,
she's,
she's naomi campbell is 45.
How old is cindy crawford?
She's just turned 15.
Noemi campbell,
45.
Still fucking slamming hot,
right?
So anyway,
she stops in the middle of this thing.
They have this,
they have these photos of her,
her book is out and it's this exclusive
book that costs like 1500 bucks or
something,
a really big,
high glossy the whole deal and she just
stops and they start taking photos of
her and she just starts posing.
So no one talks.
No one's taught like everyone's just
watching because it's naomi campbell
party,
so it's almost like Michael Bolton gets
out of his party and
well
my cell phone,
but it's like that.
She's doing her thing posing craft it an
amazing kid and there's just.
It was a kind of a fascinating little
party.
It was a good thing to dip my toe into
and get the fuck out of there as quickly
as realize why you don't go to.
Well,
it's just,
it's they're too famous to famous and
it's,
it's what it is is to me it's like,
ooh,
don't get that famous for sure.
Back off.
You're going to get weird.
Well,
everybody gets weird,
it's weird,
they're weird people and they have to
hang out with each other because nobody
else is going to understand,
you know,
and I was talking to dave about that.
I go,
do you like hanging out with celebrities
because they're the only people that
understand what your life was like.
He's like,
oh man,
but I'm not as famous as them.
I go hit the brakes.
I go,
that's part of your problem.
You don't understand how fucking famous
you are.
You're one of the most famous comedians
that's ever lived and one of the most
famous celebrities in America.
Like if there's a 100 list of the most
famous people in America,
chappelle chapels on that.
I'm not on that list.
I like to stay on the outskirts,
that list.
I like to be in the suburbs that last.
No,
jo,
I think you're in that world,
but I'm definitely not definitely.
So right now you're closing in on.
You ain't quitting.
Slowing down,
slowing down.
Thinking about moving to like yosemite,
which
you've always flirted with.
Moving out of la.
Oh yeah,
I,
I would absolutely.
I live right now.
If I give you one other alternative,
there's a few different possibilities.
I really liked Colorado have always
liked Colorado.
Colorado is always going to be one of my
best choIces.
He's been there though.
I liked the people.
I liked the environment.
I like the vibe.
I like standup community.
I like the comedy works and I love
wendy.
The owner of the comedy works.
That's the spot.
That's the spot where I could live a.
I could live in seattle.
I just couldn't deal with the winter.
I just think it's stupid.
I think regional
folks,
it rains too much up there.
Your summers are of the guys and I get
it that you have to like.
It makes you appreciate one when you
don't have the other,
but it's hard to know that all I do is
get on a jet and I could be in la and
it's perfect.
The problem in la right now is that it's
really good like comedy wines.
It's never been better.
Like there's more clubs,
there's more.
Comics is more.
Inspiration is more fun.
Meaning me and stan hope and ron white.
We're hanging out at the comedy store
there,
the night drinking and laughing and
having fun and I'm like,
where else can this take place?
It's like,
it's so rAre that you'll go there and
like a guy like ron white drops into do
15 minutes,
you know?
I mean,
that's,
that's really what it is.
I mean,
he on the list,
do 50 minutes comes by all these word
wall hanging.
Don't you think if you move to denver,
your podcast would suffer because you're
not going to have as many big guest
maybe?
I don't know.
find out who doesn't care.
You know?
I can always fly in once a week and do
that would get tired.
I probably have a free weekend flex on
it.
Well,
no,
no.
Well I can definitely fly someone there
if they were willing to go,
I could look for like local people,
but that would run dry very,
very full on denver.
Yeah.
There's no better spot than la to do
podcasts and stand up and stand up this
kit find better,
but there's also the,
the,
the vast numbers of human beings that
live in this place.
Shit,
look at the numbers were denver.
It's not the same as here,
but how many people are moving there?
I went live.
It's insane.
Oh,
you'd live back live in like evergreen.
Evergreen.
I like brunello.
It's nice.
Yeah.
Broomfield's nice.
But evergreens in the mountains.
Yeah,
that's what I like.
There's some views and evergreen or
boulder.
I like boulder a lot.
The bolded things.
It's a one note thing.
Everybody's so liberal.
They're so left wing.
I like like a little mixture.
I like.
Some are too soft and boulder from
soften went way.
Just bitches.
Oh,
just.
Yeah,
to lived there.
Just bitch.
How so?
There's just a.
There's no diversity.
It's just all white.
All white white people.
Just everyone's rich,
liberal,
rich,
white people.
If you see a black guy played football,
other than that,
they're live.
They live in this pleasantville,
this little weird bubble coMmunity.
We're in bubble.
Yeah.
Weird,
but super nice people.
Yeah,
they're educated.
It's easy to be nice when you got plenty
of food scraps,
right?
Somebody made it already.
Jamie made it while working on the show.
Jamie lewis.
Incredible golden snitch.
I might be a young,
sharp jamie,
please text me that immediately.
Must go on the insult of
the ultimate fighter shop face.
That's perfect.
I don't know man.
Um,
there's those two spots are big
candidates.
He's almost.
Well I'm thinking about like spending
time in more than one place.
You know,
the only thing that holds me back
really,
it's not really holding me back,
but having a family,
like you have to take them into
consideration when you make any move
them around.
Kids don't like that stability.
Some.
Yeah.
So I grew up there,
my to me,
but,
but I'll tell you one thing,
when they turn 18,
if they decided to go to college
somewhere and move somewhere else,
I'm ghost.
There's no,
there's no way I'm going to be doing
this in 10 years.
There's no way I'm going to because I
don't think the city sustainable.
I think the city is like a game of
musical chairs and I think after awhile
you're like,
it's going to be Mexico city.
I've been to Mexico city.
I know what it's like.
It's overwhelming.
The amount of people,
like the traffic jams are insane.
Like you go through them and you're
like,
how is this real?
Nobody gives a fuck about a red light or
a green light and when they want to
merge they just have to shut themselves
out into traffic.
Nobody lets you in.
And I remember sitting there thinking
they're watching this going,
here's this beautiful city,
this crazy ancient city in the mountains
in Mexico.
Six,
7,000 feet above sea level,
you know,
just with 20 plus million people stuffed
in it and like la is not that far off
and las growth from the time I moved
here in 1994 to today in 2016 is
unbelievable.
Twenty two years later.
Operating values are so because I know
but,
but that's going to happen here.
You think it's going to keep going,
keep going.
What's gonna happen?
People are going to wise up and become
awesome.
No,
they're gonna keep going to keep moving
here because we're show business.
See,
I'm trying to convince my dad to move
here,
especially because his grandsons here
and so he doesn't seem like that
movement.
well that's different though.
I mean that makes sense.
You know,
to live here with,
you know,
you're,
you're here,
your business is here,
and your family's here.
If that makes sense.
People will move though.
The thing is it's so expensive to live
here like anything else.
What happens is people go,
you know what,
la is great,
but you know,
this is place raleigh,
North Carolina.
They're really do with a billion
infrastructure and people move to those
places of nashville,
raleigh.
Look what happened to portland.
That's secret.
Got out.
People moved there.
So yeah,
but the secret's out the winter sucks,
but as you get like one of the things I
noticed is like I'll be in places like
that place we were in in Oklahoma slash
Arkansas and middle of nowhere.
This tiny little beautiful town.
We found the best coffee shop with the
best single source,
single origin shade,
grown coffee,
you know,
designer fucking coffee worthy of keith
jardine.
This is the kind of shit that he gets
excited about,
but
we ate great food too.
We had a great
high.
No phones.
I know Oklahoma hall.
Here's the thing.
There's good places in small towns from
20 years ago.
The internet is here and people are
evolving and changing everywhere.
It's a different world.
You can find a lot of what you liked
from big cities and small towns now more
and more,
more and more,
and I think that that it's important to
note that the look,
the only reason to be in la,
it's kind of retro until I have all
these people jammed in together.
The idea is that this is where the cool
people are.
This is where we have to live.
This is where show businesses,
but what kind of show business are you
really involved in anymore other than
the goldbergs.
I guess that's like the last traditional
client about that too and a lot of stuff
doesn't shoot in la,
but also you don't want to shoot anyway.
There's stuff that you're doing.
Most of it is you doing standup on the
road.
Are you doing your podcast on the road
or are you doing your podcast in town?
Unless you're doing dishes.
I told you the story about me turning
that thing down before the show.
I'm not doing it.
I'm not interested.
It's not as fun.
There's only so much time I want to pull
on,
get my own food in the mountain.
I dOn't want to do any of the milk.
I want to.
I want to hear elk go.
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Waiting behind a tree.
He wants to act.
Fuck you can say that until you do it.
Let me tell you something right now.
Yeah.
You take you bone,
arrow hunting sun.
You get.
You get addicted to archery.
I'll take you home.
You realize the rush of taken out of elk
and then eating it and then realizing
like,
whoa,
all the guilt and weird shit that you
have about food,
about buying it from a grocery store.
You can cut out like most of that.
Everything except for restaurants.
I've had it out when I'm eAting meat.
It's all this.
It's,
it's,
it's so.
It's,
it's exciting.
You're telling me,
well,
and now you're in.
I'm in.
I wish.
I wish it was that dangerous.
Do you wish you would?
First of all,
I want to.
I will fuck you up now.
Go well.
Fuck you.
Out of your mind.
You'll go outside and look at that
forest horse that we've got written
there.
They wOuld
run from his brother.
They might be sweatiNg me with an arrow.
He's not going to be like.
First of all,
he has to know that it's now an elk
might run a moose,
might run at you motherfucker.
A moose or the deer or moose or pretty
close,
pretty close in size.
Mooses fuck people up elk fuck people up
to.
I'm going to have to watch them videos
and for him to go,
I need to get more scared.
I need some videos of elk.
They won't.
Moose are more aggressive because moose
have are traditionally and climates that
to deal with a lot more grizzly bear
ticket.
Now if you're talking about and wolves,
the one animal that scares the shit out
of luck.
Oh my god,
the elk fucking up some snowman.
Look at the size of that thing.
You understand how things fit is big.
That's a thousand pound animal with
towards growing out of attending the
machine can bro.
Here's what terrifies me.
I didn't realize that grizzly bear
started eating you before you die.
As they started getting your ass,
well they don't kill you,
they just eat you.
You eventually.
This was going to say I was listening to
your show because I'm scared of who.
I've always been scared of horses,
but even more now I was just show him
like Mr. Hanson got gotta.
Look this up.
I went to that dark web,
found that mr han's video him.
Mr. Hansen guy.
He likes to have sex with horses.
Well,
this horse was just a little too little
too.
Balls deep in that asshole killed them.
You don't know.
You talk about it on stage.
It's a great pit.
I stopped doing it.
I didn't.
No,
no,
no.
Mr. Mr hans is a guy.
He would go into this place.
I did all this research.
I'm fucking weird.
But there's also.
It's a three men mission because camera
man,
the guy controlling that big old dick
cleaner,
your big old horse winner and then mr.
Hans is like this and so they just line
that horse up.
He puts his hooves on and then they
lined that dick into the asshole.
Well,
this horse was like boom,
son and have a setup where the guys
drove or it looks like bales of hay or
something like that or some sort of a
platform that they've designed so the
guy can bend over and then the guy puts
his asshole out and the horse,
they lift the horses legs up so his feet
are on the platform and the hig is hard
on.
They probably like jerked the horse off
first payment about two seconds.
That's how animals don't like almost
don't like fuck.
Like lexington steel and the guy died.
no,
this was like boom,
boom
noises.
We played the noises.
We played in the.
Josh has apps podcast.
We played the noises that it's like,
but he's like kind of like.
And he's like,
oh man,
he doesn't either.
He died at the hospital,
the hospital,
his friends were like,
you gotta go to the hospital.
He's like,
no,
I'm fine.
I because he worked for boeing.
He's like,
I'm not going to know.
They don't know if that video is of the
time that killed him because apparently
there's hundreds of hours of videos of
those guys getting fucked by horses.
Hundreds of hours.
Now my thing is with the government
should do is there's no sense in holding
onto that.
Not making a profit off of those
hundreds of hours.
They should take that and make a dvd,
put it up for sale and uh,
you know,
put the money back into the coffers of
the city claw.
Make Some money.
I can check it out.
It's interesting to see because this
horse is dick.
It looks like this mic.
It's literally,
it's like your arm and I'm not kidding.
And he goes,
he goes,
balls deep.
Yeah.
This horse is,
it goes through his fucking.
It just rips them apart.
It's tours colon.
Oh,
what'd you think was gonna happen?
Well,
apparently had done it a bunch of times
and survived.
I dunno man.
Or,
or done it with other animals.
And then maybe the horses.
What broke them?
Maybe try to put a safety ring on that
bad boy.
Put a safety ring.
Well,
if the guy tries to hold onto it for a
second,
who's that?
He tries to like,
you know,
like a high school girl when they're
first starting out.
Has they hold onto the.
They have like little stopper.
Yeah.
That horse is not buying that.
Just the tip.
You've got to put an inflatable safety
ring on that bad boy.
I didn't get to stop that.
Fucking males.
It's this weird.
It's weird because it's,
it's weird because they've met online in
a forum where people were turned on by
animals.
Yeah.
And then they met on this forum and then
decided to meet in this place that was
legal in Washington state.
It was legal until recently.
As long as the animal's penetrating you.
If you're penetrating the animal,
that shit's illegal son.
LIke you can't fuck a horse,
but it's you.
I guess that changed.
It's mr.
Van dyke is.
It makes sense.
That's like that guy jonathan,
so balls deep in it,
but as soon as I was that I was on the
plane just researching the shit out of
it,
but there was this guy jonathan haidt
who's a social scientist talking about
that,
like certain things are legal,
but they,
they elicit a disgust response even
though they don't hurt anybody.
So like he does this example of um,
two things where he goes,
if a brother and sister are in the woods
having sex with a condom on,
there's nothing inherently harmful to
both of them.
But all of us go,
oh,
or If the guy jerks off or if a guy
fucks a chicken,
then eats it.
We all go,
god daMn.
But it's now really the chicken's
already dead.
It's not.
And it elicits in disgust reaction even
though it technically you can't really
define why it's wrong,
why you signed to that bit about it.
But why is it okay to kill something?
But you can't fuck it after you kill it.
That's like,
you can't do that.
But if you jerked off of the chicken
cutlet,
I bet you wouldn't go to jail.
Somebody call you,
caught you fucking a chicken,
people be really mad,
but if you just took the breast,
the chicken breast wrapped around your
dick and jerked off,
no one can say shit.
Right?
But we,
we still have thIs automatic discussed,
weird to like ground beef.
If you take ground beef and you know,
you just take like
warm it up to like body temperature and
like a plastic ziploc bag,
wrap it around your dick and just start
jerking yourself with this warm basal a
terrible.
And you knew that you allowed to do
that.
I guess you can do that
where people might not invite
you to their cocktail party,
but if you get caught fucking a pig,
even if the pigs having a great old
time,
I'll give you a fucking pig.
And the pigs like loving it,
loving it.
Is that,
is that your big impression pig?
Just really hitting at the right spot
that pigs like,
oh
that's illegal.
That's illegal.
Like even if the pig like finds you and
starts backing up towards you since you
out.
But if you bend over in that pigs like,
yo,
let me get that at that asshole.
It's legal.
Let's go back to danville.
No talking.
No,
it's not necessarily legal and I don't
think it's legal in Washington state
anyMore.
Mr dan stein.
But it's not like a proactive active.
It's like it's.
I think it's illegal to just be engaging
in sex.
I think it's like,
oh,
I don't know.
In a weird who gives us the questions
like can you do body parts?
No.
Well,
what about the guy who paid the guy to
kill them and eat them?
And they ate.
They ate his genitals together.
They need is.
They stick together.
Like technically there was a legal
quagmire.
There were.
They were like,
well the guy did put an ad out and he
didn't want to craigslist and we end.
You cannibalized him together.
Is the.
Did the guy wind up dying?
Oh yes.
He wanted to be slaughtered.
Put an ad out on craigslist.
And where was that?
And some dude was like,
oh,
I'll do it.
And he's like,
listen with the dealers,
you got eat my dick first.
That dick like kobiashi up barbecue that
trains japanese man 22 cooks his own
genitals and serve them.
Know this is a different one.
This is fucking.
No,
this is a guy who didn't like his
gender.
He was asexual.
So he decided to cut his dick and balls
off and then serve them.
Did they?
Did the party?
No though.
Or is it like hannibal style?
No,
he.
They knew they were garnished with
mushrooms and parsley.
they paid a 160.
What is that?
Pounds per person.
Way too much.
Way too much to eat.
His severed genitalium mushrooms and
parsley.
I like mine with lemon damn paper.
You get everything though.
You get the shaft,
the testes and the scrotum.
look at this.
He cooked the genitalia himself as he
was supervised by a chef.
Whoa.
In a tweet.
He offered to cook his penis for a guest
for whatever.
That's quickly.
mark,
male genitals,
full penis testes.
Scrotum them as a meal for 100,000.
In the end,
that's 800 pounds.
So that's roughly what?
A thousand dollars.
1,200 little asian guy though.
That's a
dollar less than dollar.
Now it varies,
right?
It's more now it's worth more.
So 800 pounds,
like a thousand.
He decided to split the meal between six
guests.
So you're not getting a lot of dick for
your money.
The organs were surgically removed at
age 22.
I was tested to be free of venereal
diseases.
The organs were of normal function.
I was not receiving female hormone
treatment,
so he took the dick and balls away a
year ago.
A year before.
Shit.
That shit on ice.
Oh my god.
Well that's probably going to tenderize
it a little bit.
That works with elk meat.
Yeah.
It depends how you let it simmer.
It depends how you let it.
I mean,
it's freezing.
You freeze it for a year.
It actually breaks down some of the
tissue,
especially that scrotum.
A lot of guys who hunt moose,
they don't eat it for like six months to
rainelle.
His brother told him that dick would be
pretty soft,
like a filet.
I feel safe.
I feel really sick.
I know,
but so.
So what about the six people in this
tiny dick?
Like calamari?
Not good.
The other guy's a different story
though.
Find them out.
The guy who hired someone to kill them
and eat them.
Yeah,
that one's different one,
but there's a lot of weird dick eaton
people who the fuck signing up to go to
that dinner.
You guys go over chinsey,
but then you call them crazy.
What do you guys know about the japanese
guy?
There's a japanese guy who killed a
woman in adr and did a little bit of
time in jail and somehow or another got
off or got out and now is a celebrity
and he jokes around about eating people.
He murdered some gIrl in adr and now he
does like pictures,
like the japanese culture is very
different than ours and he does these
like pictures where he pretends to be
like biting people's like a scary,
strange fetish celebrity.
I'm trying to remember the dude's name
ozawa or something like that.
You find them.
I was looking for that,
but you started almost say,
I found this was even weirder.
When is this article?
That damn things in the way.
Oh man,
slices are down at the bottom of it.
You can get rid of it.
No.
See the right below that audible.
Oh my god.
They're all popping up.
This is gross.
Oh my god.
Look at things that pop up.
I feel sick.
I feel physically sick.
Thing he's eaten.
Dick ill.
You can't get rid of that ad.
Oh my god.
Audible.
Oh,
there it goes.
Okay.
Oh,
it's like a coding issue.
Huh?
I see.
Interesting though.
It's going to.
Things that you've researched like
richard dawkins,
the god delusion mediator.
Sam harris,
a woman's slices off rapists genitalia.
Forces him to eat it at gun type.
Move that cool because this guy came in,
he raped her.
Keep going down.
We'll get that guy's face and then she
convicted.
Child molester,
tied him up and he grabbed the knife and
castrated him.
Wow.
Is that the plot of a save after
drinking massive amounts of alcohol and
was able to untie herself and then she
basically.
I'm with that.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Awesome.
She should've killed chunk in the
microwave,
grabbed the plate fork and steak knIfe
and cut it up like hot dogs.
Wow.
Enforcement gun that he had left on the
kitchen counter,
walked over to him,
force him to eat it.
I have no remorse and I'm not sorry.
That bastard deserved it and he's going
to get in trouble.
I agree with her.
You
see now that's a case where I think that
girls should get a medal me to.
Why are we celebrating her?
Why is she in trouble?
Find out she's in trouble.
I hope not be hilarious because she
loves.
Kill him.
Right?
Just fed them that dick that's allowed.
That should cut his dick off.
Amen.
You can't say self defense.
Well,
she was tied up.
Got out.
Cut that dickoff force.
Indeed it.
Yeah.
He needs to die.
Of course.
Well now he's.
It's almost batteries alive now because
he could still hurt people.
Good luck in jail.
You know a lot of those guys.
What they're doing is psychological.
You know what?
It's fake.
Damn god damn well that the picture.
I was like,
well,
that pIcture of jamie snopes it.
Fake news site posing as the los angeles
area outlet.
Ktlk.
Spread a fabricated but juicy tail as
shovels,
truman's revenge
plot from the girl with the tattoo.
Whatever the fuck it was.
It was
like heaven.
I seen that.
That rapist,
she fucked them up.
Feed them as dIck,
but she fucks them up and writes like
horror or whatever on his back.
And then two good move man s cbre on,
but we're all in agreement of something
like that.
You know,
you see on like the possibility of
someone actually doing that and how you
support it.
I'm 100 percent in agreement with me to
brian.
He checking the tweet.
see if people love.
Now I'm not.
I'm seeing.
I'm seeing when we have see a.
You guys have a meeting.
What time is your meeting?
I don't know.
I just got a call from my agent.
I may have to listen to it real quick.
What are you guys doing?
Business.
a big shot in the streets right now.
Victim of cannibal agreed to be eating.
Eaten to the family next door.
Oh,
this guy seems like perfect neighbor.
He mowed their lawn,
repair their car,
even invited them round for dinner.
Other residents in the small german town
of rottenberg also believed there was
nothing odd about the 42 year old
computer expert who's light burned late
into the night inside his creaking
mansion yesterday,
however,
news appeared in court,
charged with killing and then frying and
eating another man.
Wow.
Shit,
right?
Yeah.
He met the 43 year old berlin engineer
burn brandiS after advertising on the
internet and had chopped him up and
eaten him.
It was.
He said something he had wanted to do
for a long time.
came in.
I always wanted.
I always had the fantasy and in the end
I fulfilled it.
Muse said to the court,
and his first day was trial for murder
and the nearby city of castle.
Yesterday,
german prosecutors described how muse
had fantasized about killing and
devouring someone,
including his classmates.
from the age of eight.
The desire grew stronger after the death
of his mother in 1999.
Prosecutor marcus kohler said in march
of 2001 muse advertise on the internet
for a young well built man who wanted to
be eaten.
Oh,
he advertised.
So he asked if anybody wants to be eaten
on this goes down.
Yeah.
So it Was the opposite.
And the evening of march nine,
two men went to the bedroom in muse,
rambling,
timbered farmhouse,
mr brandis swallowed 20 sleeping tablets
and half a bottle of shops before muse
cutoff.
Brandon says penis with his agreement
and fried it for both of them to eat a
dick.
Well fried dick brandis by this stage,
bleeding heavily.
Then took a bath while muse read a star
trek novel.
Gangster.
The guy cut his dick off and he,
he went and read a book while the guy
bled out in a tub star,
track it to the bath,
needs a starch.
How much blood is coming out of this
guy?
Like why?
How do you even?
Okay.
And the early hours of the morning,
he finished off his victim by stabbing
him in the neck with a large kish kiss
kitchen,
knife,
kissing him first was some weird shit.
The cannibal then chop mr.
Brennan says into pieces and put several
bits of him in his freezer next to a
takeaway pizza and buried the skull and
his garden.
Over the next few weeks,
he defrosted and cooked parts of mr
brenda's in olive oil and garlic.
eventually consuming 20 kilograms of
human flesh before police finally turned
up at his door with my every bite.
My memory of him grew stronger,
crazy behind bars.
Muse told detectives that he first
consumed his victim with the bottom of
south african red wine,
had got out his best cutlery and
decorated his dinner table with candles.
He toasts.
He tasted of pork.
He said he added low jesus christ.
It's not illegal.
Yeah.
The unprecedented case had proven
problematic for german lawyers who
discovered the cannibalism is not
illegal in Germany,
but it's murder.
Okay,
so Instead they've charged me with
murder for the purposes of sexual
pleasure and with disturbing the peace
of the dead.
Oh shit.
There's video.
This was crucial to the case is a
gruesome videotape made of the entire
evening during which brand is apparently
makes clear his consent.
Whoa.
I'm trying to see that deep front dick.
Go down and we'll see what that's like.
Oh my god.
Before setting off on is one way journey
to rottenberg.
Brandis was outwardly at least a
successful financially secure
professional with a live in girlfriend
jesus christ,
living girlfriend after killing after
killing brendan,
the german cannibal met five other men
who have responded to with internet
advert,
including one from london.
The best part did not,
however,
kill theM because his girlfriend broke
up with him.
It was revealed that he liked men.
Jesus.
Well,
he likes to eat them.
I eat dick's.
Go.
yeah.
Is that a problem for you?
Listen to this.
In july of 2001,
a students stumbled over muse chat room
and alerted the german authorIties who
arrested him last december,
so he was out running around for awhile.
How long was the time between december
and when he killed the dude?
I don't know.
There are a lot of people like this guys
messed up.
He,
he ate 20 kilograms.
The guy's body.
Twenty kilograms is 44 pounds.
That's 44 meals.
A lot of it went to waste.
I don't know.
That has a 200 pound man know he needed
all.
He still had some of it.
They caught him before he could finish.
What does this say?
The trip?
Pretrial interview.
The cannibal said that after eating
brandis he felt much better and more
stable.
This bitch said he finished.
That is about having blog blonde,
young brother who could keep forever.
Pike consuming him.
Hey man.
You batshit crazy.
Whoa.
Although they say that serial killers
like they get the final step is when
they start eating and drinking the blood
of the victims because it's their way of
consuming and having complete and total
power over and he only gets five years
in jail though.
Wow.
That's how that fucks back on the
streets and five.
He's already back in the street then
because I feel like the story was five
years ago.
Scroll,
scroll up longer than mIne.
I got up and made a movie about this
2013.
So it was three.
Oh,
three,
2003.
He's out.
he's out eating.
Yeah.
Google this motherfucker.
Arman.
Google that guy and put the word
released.
Look at him.
He looks like it got cut your dick.
Oh my god.
He's a terrifying dude.
He dIdn't win the lottery.
When came to looks.
Hey,
we look at his fucking face in the
interview with a campaign is an
interview with him,
set of chompers on them to do.
Did they make a movie about this?
Um,
I don't think they did.
I got to see it.
Video original.
No way.
What is that movie?
I think that's the movie.
Grim up.
Ready for the original.
Oh my god.
My mind.
Is there a real video?
Oh,
that's,
those are clay puppets.
That shit look real though for a second.
Oh my god.
They should like with his dick.
Cut off with the shoulder.
So that's the real one,
man.
That's him splitting the guy down the
middle.
What would that?
Yeah.
Don't show people,
but that's him.
That's him splitting the guy down.
Yeah.
Okay.
That,
that was the real pictures.
That guy hang hung by his ankles and
split theM down.
The middle lake bled them out into
buckets and shit.
Boy,
they say that the was the guy who
probably got stabbed.
He said he stabbed him in the neck.
It's prObably killed him.
He probAbly hung them upside down and
killed a man.
God is hitman.
Uh,
Richard,
uh,
ted,
what was the guy's name?
Who was the iceman?
Kalinski,
yeah,
he,
he said that they would do is they would
hang the body,
bleed it,
and then chop it up,
take it out to a boat and just either
drop it off the boat or they would bring
it to one of those car mashing places
and put the body under a car.
15 other cars and you'd just be,
you know.
Yeah.
I read this book called murder machine.
Joey diaz gave it to me back in the day.
It was all about this guy who was a mob,
roy de mayo,
I think his name was.
He was a mob assassin who just became a
fucking complete on full on psychopath,
serial killer who killed god,
knows how many people just kill people
left and right for whatever fucking
reason you want it to.
And this,
this pLace that they lived his bar area
where they had like an apartment
upstairs and he used to kill people in
this apartment.
These fucking killed like 100 people
there.
There's,
he just got addicted to killing.
And this is a book about.
He is in his words,
well,
it's his story.
The investigators,
they caught him.
They caught him,
but it's a disturbing book,
man.
It's
one of those books where you go,
well,
you just have to realize those people
are out there.
They're out there.
Stuff makes me sick.
That's it should.
That's why we need tim kennedy.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Here it is.
An interview with a cannibal.
Documentaries sheds new light on one of
germany's most infamous murders and this
is from 2016.
IT's on youtube.
I was just looking at it,
so he's free.
The documentary for eight years.
It's what I found out.
He said it became a vegetarian while I
was in jail as well.
Kenny takes until
he's going to come out and he's going to
start eating people again,
you even 40 pounds of may and then I'm
like,
nah,
man,
I'm not into meat anymore.
How much do you think they'd have the
footage of the act itself,
which was shown in a closed room to the
trial is described in the documentary as
too disturbing to show and so shocking
that only 19 minutes of the four hour
video was shown.
His behavior as a child was described as
like most other children his age.
He loved animals and found country life
idealic.
Well,
some people are just crazy.
The other guy.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's the guy.
Hey,
he looks stable.
That guy wanted to be butchered because
hIs.
Because his girlfriend caught them with
men.
Is that what it was?
It tasted the flesh taste like pork,
but stronger.
Jesus christ.
It's just amazing that he's free now.
I'm.
I almost wish I could speak german so I
could understand what he's saying to
bring his dumb ass in here with a
translator.
You don't want to hear it.
Well,
I don't know,
man.
I'm not going to kill you guys.
It's almost like a no.
Bring him in.
No,
that's never happened in with a
translator like ufc interview in german.
That guy knowing where I am,
we just notice what your studios that
maybe we bring them here to kill him.
You start caring.
I want to start carrying two guns.
Gun isn't an acuity gun,
But he's not going to kill you.
Everyone here.
Can you let?
Yeah.
If you let him kill you,
he'll eat you.
If you give them any sort of light like,
yeah,
you know,
I'm kind of depressed.
He's killing needs help with wine.
But there are people in vans right now
trolling around looking for someone to
eat.
I don't think so.
Definitely.
I mean it was too.
It goes back to what we're talking about
when we're talking about bathrooms and
transgender people and the the amount of
creeps that are actually not
transgender,
just sexual predators
to come up with a way to get someone in
the vein right now.
There's a small amount of People right
now in this country,
just this country that are fighting off
the urge to commit rape and murder
monsters.
Right?
Tell me a white van,
a group of dudes is driving around la
toronto people probably not,
but likely somewhat.
Look,
all they have to do is one crime or
someone drinks someone's blood and kill
someone by biting him in the neck and
then it becomes a copycat.
People are weird.
I met a girl who she was.
We were talking and said,
well,
I've,
I've had trouble getting on my phone too
much.
We're ruining brendan.
I met a girl who said she couldn't get.
She had said she'd had a tough time last
two years and I was trying to ask her.
Finally,
she said,
well,
my,
my cousin was killed.
my first cousin was killed,
and I said,
oh.
She said this guy was killing men.
He wAs spiking their drInks.
He would take them outside,
have sex with them and then kill them
and that there are people that just do
weird shit that just kind of predators.
They set their whole life up
and told me there's people in pants.
Look around deep people.
There's people that are with puppies as,
as long as an is cadbury eggs and
twizzlers.
That's how you get him in the fucking
van.
Especially.
We just put some twizzlers and were
done.
What happened?
I am,
but if you put in my face like the
cadbury egg,
like yoda,
ugly this week.
Oh shit.
What's this?
When do a goddamn thing to me?
Listen,
if you really weak this,
um,
chili mangoes faze me.
I haven't cheated.
Yeah.
Doug and I said something else in that
bag.
If I walked in and you had fresh cadbury
eggs,
peel from the wrapper without those
chili mangoes.
We actually just opened one of those
bags.
let you smell it.
I'll get excited.
Well,
if you had the five or you can only five
foods,
what would they be?
Temporary eggs and my five foods
forever.
well I would,
if I,
if I was restricted to that,
I would do it only based on nutrition.
So elk,
elk meat?
Yeah.
I would eat something like that.
Wild game,
meat,
avocados,
healthy vegetables like kale.
It would be all boring shit because it
will help me.
It's not boring,
but if I,
you know that I would have to like leave
it at that.
But I think if you only ate five things,
you'd probably going to get sick unless
you're supplementing yourself.
You've goT to make sure you're getting a
proper amount of vitamin c.
You'd be fucking chance.
I'd imagined yams,
kale,
avocado,
elk.
You get a lot of stuff there.
Right?
I think people benefit more than other
animals too,
on a variety of different foods.
On varying your diet.
Yeah.
More like animals have a problem with
that.
Like dogs,
like you can't switch up dog food if you
give a dog one kind of food,
then you give him something else.
Just get explosive babies the same way
though.
Like if you changed the formula baby
shit everywhere.
Can you get too much iron from eating
meat every day?
Shows much iron.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I've never heard that.
I had high iron,
high iron count one time when I went and
got my blood done.
How much media you.
But he said,
he said,
but he said,
you know,
it's fucking crazy.
I was cooking from a cast iron.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
And the cast iron iron in your food
tray.
Siren because.
Hi ferris.
I levels.
Yeah,
I cook a lot.
And iron pants.
That's the best thing for you.
It's a good way to get iron.
Yeah.
Probably a good way for people to get
iron to that are vegetarians like if you
feel like that's exactly what they tell
vegetarians to cook in a cast iron
skillet.
Yeah.
That's a good way to do it because you
get low iron if you're a vegetarian,
you also get a lot of creatine if you're
eating a lot of red meat,
like you don't need a dose on created.
I used to take so much creatine,
but because it's not a little lot of red
meat,
stuff like that.
Don't take any credit.
So you're doinG your keto genic right?
Yeah.
I think creatine is like legit
supplement.
It's one of the few legit supplements
that actually does really increase your
strength.
I've been taken in.
Recovery does.
It's legit.
You know,
a lot of these things that like the tool
goes back to the yoel yoel romero thing
and even adjust jeff novitsky thing.
A lot of the Stuff that we see in these
stores like gnc and health stores that
have these muscle building things,
a lot of those things are really
steroids really now.
Yeah.
Form like,
wow,
you guys keep pissing hot from the usada
has a website that we,
when novitsky was here,
he sent us to the website and you go
like a through z,
you find whatever the supplement is and
you list to see if whether or not people
have been popped for it,
like they test and and they pull these
things off the market and they just come
back with some new name.
They switch.
Remember mark maguire,
the stuff he was using,
you could buy at jet style.
I took that shit that you get by.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well sort of as a steroid precursor
hormone precursor,
but here's the deal.
He wasn't thinking that he's holding his
fucking whatever.
Even think he was taking that for the
fuck of it.
Just to see how he fell maybe,
but he was injecting straight to this,
that anderson and worked a little but he
was.
He was on the is that you see how like
I,
it's been a,
it's been a less than me where I looked
back and I,
I realized when you play sports in the
weights,
nobody's 240 pounds in just that jack.
I mean some people have a lot of
professionals you don't do.
You don't go from being.
That's true,
but you don't want me one 85 when you're
25 and then the big dramatic difference,
especially if they're like a veteran.
Yeah,
something's up,
but there's a lot of freaks.
You can achieve some incredible results
with discipline and the right protocol
with hypertrophy.
You could eat a lot of food all day
long,
lift crazy weights and when you're
young,
if your body holds up to the workload,
you can put on some massive weight when
you're young,
when your hormones are strong,
if you do it the right way,
like say if you had like a strength
lifting coach and you said,
hey,
I want to gain 20 pounds of muscle.
If you had to do it right now,
they would go,
oh,
we got to fuck with your hormones.
Like you're too old at this point that,
but if you want,
but if you were 20 and you did the same
thing to your body type,
I don't really think I could do,
you know,
it's hard for me to put on any muscle
maybe.
But You're not a guy who's ever tried
and you don't really know if your
program.
YeaH.
Yeah.
You're not frail,
you know,
I mean your skin.
You're not running weightlifting guy
though,
right?
Like you don't live.
I do lyft but not like that.
How often do you left?
Probably twice a week and twice a week
is fine.
When you lift,
you lift heavy weights.
I try to like where am I failure at six.
Eight.
Put your guys doing more of a cardio
like circuit,
right?
A dead lifts,
squats,
bench.
Well I'll do like lately,
like I'll go from deadlift to pull ups,
you know,
where and the deadlift is what by the
eighth I'm hurting,
you know.
But again I'll do that once a week,
you know?
And then I'll do a maybe some bench with
like 60 pound dumbbells and then I'll do
mine.
Yeah.
Almost a 49.
Well,
you know,
one of the things about [inaudible] is
interview with tim ferriss.
He was talking about his dad getting
involved in power lifting when he was in
his sixties is he taught his dad power
lifting was dad was in his sixties and
like six,
seven years later he put on x amount of
pounds of muscle and he said he looks
like a 40 year old man now from like if
you see his back and he did.
I think if you did leave my skeptical
hippo.
Hippo.
I didn't know about skeptical,
skeptical hippo.
Jamie,
bring that up.
Bring that.
Bring that up.
By the way,
when you.
Powerlifting is good.
If you do it right.
I think it's probably good for your
hormones and good for your body.
Like I feel good when I lift heavy,
like I have more energy that releases
testosterone.
Next sheet.
Yeah.
That's good for you.
Well,
with pavel things
when you told me that six year old put
on lps,
that's my face,
right?
That's fucking hilarious.
I've never seen from the more skeptical
he was talking about with ferris was
talking about or pavel was talking about
rather was his protocol,
which is that never more than five
repetitions and never go to failure.
Like,
oh,
really?
Yeah,
his ideas that if you say if you lift
something and like the most reps you can
do is like seven,
cut it off at five and and put it down
and that strength is a skill and that
you want what he calls the greasing the
groove,
like doing something over and over
again,
giving yourself plenty of time in
between it so that you,
you're strong,
you're fully recovered and you'll get
stronger and you'll get stronger fast.
Who's thIs guy?
Pavel tatsumi.
He's the godfather of kettlebells.
A guy that came to America and started a
kettlebell programs like all kettlebell
instruction pretty much came out of that
guy because I've.
Yes,
he does.
Yeah,
he does live in santa monica.
I will take out the back of 75 year old
dead lifter 100 percent drug free.
That's his dad.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I mean,
who knows?
Maybe his dad,
some fuckinG savage and freak.
Yeah,
for sure.
Again,
he ended up pissing this.
Yeah.
Hey,
a golden snitch.
Vlp again.
Get on it.
No,
I don't want to piss test.
We're going to with a guy like that guy.
Like how long has that work at us and an
hour question.
Good question.
Doing all that rest.
Well,
what I do is what I've been doing over
the last few weeks since I listen to
this podcast is,
you know,
because I have stuff at home.
I have a little gym in my house,
so what I'll do is I just start working
out,
well not even in the garage,
inside the house.
I have a weight gym so I'll go and I'll
just lift weights during the day and
then I'll do it later at night.
Like a lift weights,
like I'll go home now and I'll do a few
sets of chin ups and some kettle bell
swings and curls and stuff or a and
cleans and stuff like that.
Then later that night I'll do like clean
squat press.
I'll do some some different shit and
I'll do my psets throughout the daylight
that split it instead of smashing it in,
but my cardio I still do in one big set,
so what I do like to do for cardio is I
like to lift weights first and get
really fucking tired.
Then once I'm really tired,
I do like balls out cardio for a half
hour already exhausted and then I feel
it's more of a mental thing for me is my
cardio and that's great.
Great.
I've been doing get my cardio in with my
lifting,
so I'll do like heavy deadlifts and the
set is whatever set of 10 of heavy
deadlifts.
I go straight from there to the
treadmill and I'll sprint as fast I can
for a minute.
Unlike level 10,
11,
12,
just literally as fast as I can and I go
to pull ups.
We do that for five heavy debt.
That's awesome.
Three 15.
If I'm doing 10,
it's a lot because you do five rounds.
Yeah,
the
deadly heavy dead lifts for me,
cardio was me the fun for me.
I do the cross bar where I stand in the
middle of it,
you know,
and I do deadlift with that,
that,
that to me,
is that what I.
That's my always my go to,
they say specifically that bar,
like using that trap bar for deadlIfts
is one of the best ways to like excite
your entire system safest to one of the
safest,
but it's also like you're gripping it
the way you're gripping it.
Like there's something weird about that
over under grip that you do with a
standard dumbbell and then you bang it
off your shins and straighten your
backup.
But this motherfucker is like right in
the group so you could have really
excellent posture,
puts less of a load on your lower back
and you could really fucking stack up
with some heavy weight.
You can do some cool stuff with two
farmer's walk.
Oh yeah.
I was thumbing through a book called the
supple leopard kelly start.
Yeah.
Did you see?
That?
Looks really cool.
You see what dalea did still?
He didn't know who kelly start was.
He didn't know kelly starr was a famous
strength conditioning guy.
I just saw a ridiculous photo of him.
He does look,
so he did this long.
You know,
dalea has a hilarious.
I saw that.
I see as these long,
huge run on sentences of how fucked up
these guys are.
And he did it with kelly start and is
one of the funniest things he's looking
at.
He said,
I mean,
this dude,
I can't stop laughing.
Does he know the camera can zoom out and
he can put his head regular and looks
like he's trying to peek into the lens.
Say you guys fucking or can I come in?
He just keeps going on and on and on and
on.
Most peaking this motherfucker ever even
tom is like,
he peaks more than me.
He says,
I'm dying.
This guy looks like he hurt his neck
five seconds ago.
It's really hard.
Long.
He keeps going and going.
I didn't want to read it all,
but it's like you said,
this is the look that you give a guy
when you're fucking his wife after he
fucked.
Your wife
is so fun.
I retweeted it,
but please go to chris's account.
Good,
funny motherfucker.
Oh,
he's hIlarious.
She's another good dude too,
man.
it's nice having him around the store is
fun.
He's the best.
He's
one of my favorite people in the store
is on fire.
You know what else on fire fighter and
the kid this weekend live in boston.
Ladies and gentlemen.
The wilbur theater.
That's right.
The truck affiliated saturday as well
and don't forget to saint e's and
borrow,
but we might be sold out or almost
nashville tomorrow so that in New York,
but not so loud that you guys.
You guyS are in nashville tomorrow for
the company.
Talk to them on frIday.
How long have you guys there for?
One night.
You go to New York,
then we got to boston,
then we go to the truck and around
philly and I'm like,
I'm sure with shows there what you asked
me to come see me,
we should organize some gigs,
like at least in the same town together.
Have you done,
have you done the helium in st louis or
is that.
I've only done helium in portland,
which is fucking outstanding and
chilies,
which is my best client I'm doing.
I'm doing their club in st louis,
June 9th,
10th and 11th.
So get your tickets.
I liked that website.
Who did that website?
I brother.
Your brother's a website designer was a
beast.
he does all my brother makes websites.
Really.
Does he do it professionally?
Is you just do it for you?
How long did it take them to use
squarespace to.
Oh no.
yep.
This is squarespace.
Dude.
This is a beast.
This is really good.
A great job.
The photographs in the background are
awesome.
All our merchandise hat.
I did that from a photo shoot and
abraham lincoln.
Karate.
Goddamn right.
you ever had like a vampire slayer?
So are just.
We covered the ufc.
I knew this wasn't going to be a ufc
podcast.
We always somewhat.
Some kind of.
We talked about it.
Yeah.
I just still don't want.
Why I want to know what's the latest
deleah sent me a text.
Totally unrelated,
lIke didn't know that we were doing a
podcast.
Probably didn't know we were even
talking about him and he sent me a text
about kelly.
Start retweeting that thing,
thinking it's hilarious.
And he said,
guy seems cool.
I love that shit when people get jokes.
So delete just sent me this psychic
connection mattered.
But that's what's crazy is that like
that picture that I put up was days ago
and the fact that he said it literally
texted me while we were talking about
how weird.
That is.
Weird.
What are you going to do,
dude?
It's spooky.
Man
can trash.
The earth is flat.
He got owned.
I got owned by crystal.
Earth is flat,
but he's.
Kelly's a good guy.
He's hilarious.
Yeah,
I don't take it too well.
I don't think he was probably in the
middle of a video and someone took a
still of it and use it as a photo or he
was like,
make sure you get this angle doing
mobility stuff.
He knows his shit.
Huh?
I'll fuck you.
He's the guy that came up with the idea
of using those hard balls like lacrosse
balls to loosen up muscles.
Oh,
it's the best.
There's a lot of good information out
there.
The other is more than ever before.
I'm going to get huge with that russian
guy and I'm going to work with.
I'm going to be.
I'm going to be a fucking big leopard.
A big supple leopard.
well,
he's all mobility.
he's a big mobiLity.
It's all about having a full range of
motion,
flexibility and full range of motion
with all your tissues.
nothing being tight and wound up and so
he's all about like breaking up scar
tissue,
stretching yourself out,
making sure that you're strong and all
these different areas and you don't
create these vulnerable so you should
hit them up and spend a lot of time with
them because I fucking enter the same
muslim,
my neck man every once every three
months.
Start jerking guys off.
Stops talking to mom.
All rigHt,
just head movement guy.
Fuck your head.
Just tell them I've been happy.
Happy to blow you all these years.
Butcher me and eat me afterwards.
We had a guy,
I it got a guy who fuck you and he
kissed the guy in the phase right before
stabbed in the neck.
I think what a gentleman,
a person wandering around Germany.
This is him up Like a,
just die.
We're all going to die.
Got to get them on the show.
Dressing him up like an infidel
sentiment to the muslim neighborhoods or
rails.
This fucking podcast
[inaudible] dot com.
Brendan schaub on twitter.
Bryan with a y on twitter and see fucker
soon.
Thanks everybody.
Bye.
Oh,
I'll be back tonight.
Podcasts at 9:00 PM,
but bobcat goldthwait back from a big
foot convention.